[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut à toi Kevin
j'espère que tu vas très très bien salut
stuff salut à tous ça va très très bien
de mon côté sauf je suis très heureux de
te rejoindre pour un nouveau stream ça
fait un petit moment d'ailleurs donc
très content plus les matchs sont hyper
sympas ça va être un bel événement à
commentaire
il fallait il fallait bien il fallait
bien
tu vas pas faire d'ennemis sur le chat
c'est vrai que Laurent de me dire que
c'était un fallait passer par là des
fois il y avait un truc il fallait il
fallait avoir un stream avec toi et
c'était un peu moins terrible mais donc
en fait je suis assez content quand même
je vais te dire un truc je pense que
Laurent est très jaloux que je sois avec
toi je le connais à Laurence c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça à chaque fois il
jalouse quand c'est bon voilà bon c'est
la vie il s'en remettra il s'en remettra
quand même maintenant il a il a
l'expérience et tout ça Laurent il est
assez âgé quand même donc il aura de
quoi s'en remettre voilà
[Musique]
et
du coup alors aujourd'hui on a on a de
pommade en perspective on va vous les
montrer alors j'ai je vous ai mis en
place un petit un petit bracket qui est
là donc il est il est à jour
je peux vous le montrer de suite
technique au top sauf maintenant ouais
alors regardez il est il est ici
normalement ça devrait s'afficher et
vous avez ici alors aujourd'hui on va
commencer par la poule déperlant ça veut
dire ceux qui sont en bas vous voyez
loser Quatar finals on aura karwana
contre le français à dire aux gens et en
même temps on aura aussi collars contre
bar le français le jeu de Moussard donc
Jules qui est passé sur le c'est à dire
sur le plateau sur le stream les deux
jours précédents donc très sympa on
espère qu'il va aussi pouvoir passer
aujourd'hui et qui bien sûr en prime on
rabatic au larse donc nos deux matchs
aujourd'hui de donc chez les perdants
donc c'est le match en deux parties et
si égalité à l'issue de partie et ben on
aura un Armageddon
et ensuite une fois que vous avez fait
et ben on aura un match pendant quatre
parties plus éventuellement Armageddon
entre adventure of et Van forest donc
qui je trouve depuis le début à
ultra impressionnant c'est parti c'est
linéaire quoi mais c'est sûr et
aujourd'hui on a vraiment des matchs
quand même sur le papier qui sont assez
serré évidemment avec de loin un
appareil manque plus favorable pour pour
Jules évidemment après on a vu que Colas
dans le tournoi il a battu Ali resa donc
bon après tu m'avais raconté le match un
peu rocambolesque entre guillemets
puisqu'il y avait une énorme gaffe
d'aller resa donc bon c'est quand même
plus favorable sur le papier maintenant
faut confirmer sur l'échiquets ce sont
tous des joueurs 26 plus des fois 27
plus des fois presque 28 donc il y a
tout le gratin qui est présent donc il y
a pas de match facile
et après il y a un autre tournoi et en
plus après ça enfin il y a trois poules
tu vois il y a poule 1 2 3 et le niveau
il se construit et après on disait avec
Laurent hier que c'est vrai qu'il y a en
ce moment le grand cesto aussi qui fait
quand même que il y a pas mal de gens
qui sont privés un peu entre guillemets
un de l'événement donc il manque des
joueurs mais du coup ça favorise aussi
un petit peu la présence de nouveaux
joueurs sur le plateau on aime bien on
accolar on a vu qui est ici et bon ça
c'est on va dire et puis il y a aussi
manœuvre qui était
déjà vu ces joueurs là quand on fait
quand on voit les mondes rapides les
mondes de Blitz franchement ce sont des
joueurs qu'on aperçoit qu'ils sont juste
derrière à essayer de frapper à la forte
de l'élite mondial quoi tout simplement
mais en tout cas c'est cool on va vous
montrer maintenant je crois que vous
voyez mon écran ça a pas du tout c'est
pas ce que je voulais faire
donc les joueurs qui sont déjà installés
on a fait rousse 20 en bas on a carwana
en haut on va plus ta caméra voilà et
donc tu es parti ils sont tenter
commenter à 17h et vous savez qu'on a
souvent un petit peu de d'attente entre
les entre les parties donc on va voir en
tout cas j'attends que les parties se
lancent normalement c'est entre les
parties mais là c'est dès le démarrage
voilà
et
donc voilà donc trois matchs qu'on va
voir aujourd'hui c'est le match c'est
intéressant et surtout moi ce que je
tiens aussi à souligner par rapport à ce
match là c'est qu'on a quand même pas
mal de joueurs qui sont qui sont qui
sont jeunes et nouveaux donc tu as
l'impression que la hiérarchie est un
petit peu un peu bousculé tu vois bon il
y a vente forest punky là depuis un
petit moment mais pas tant que ça tu
vois et on va quand même qui est tout
nouveau sur le circuit on a un virus là
qui a le même âge que comme ça et de
l'autre côté même ta jamais
vues qui sont là et en fait ben
on les connaît pas trop enfin nous on
connaît Jules tu vois mais c'est des
joueurs un peu nouveau sur le circuit et
c'est hyper cool tu vois
tout à fait et de voir aussi que les
jeunes m'apprendraient se sont hyper
dangereux car wanna et là aussi mon
carbone ça fait des lustres qu'on est
dans le top 5 mondial donc on va plus le
présenter maintenant mais en tout cas
c'est intéressant de voir tout ça et
[Musique]
en plus on a des Français stuff donc on
aime on aime bien on aime bien ce
côté-là c'est c'est agréable de suivre
Jules qu'on a vu évoluer en fait depuis
tout petit puisqu'on l'a connu très très
jeune pour ma part c'était au
championnat du monde quand il était en
tout petit de catégorie il me semble que
c'était en moins de 8 ans en 2003 ça
serait à vérifier mais
en tout cas la cause bah ouais tu tu
suis le petit jeune qui un jour ben ça
proche des
[Musique]
les jeunes qui arrivent bah ils ont
envie de s'inviter à la table et bah du
coup ils font les efforts nécessaires
alors que les autres sont plus sur leurs
acquis en fait tout simplement on a vu
même Carlsen abandonné son titre en
disant bah c'est très dur de de préparer
le cheval du monde il était plus après à
faire ses efforts et je pense que c'est
dû aussi au fait que bah il y a d'autres
choses dans la vie qui puissent
s'intéresser il a il a dévoué sa vie
depuis un moment aux échecs donc c'est
pas évident ce côté là de rester au top
tout le temps alors on m'a dit qu'il y
avait des bruits en fait les bruits
c'était c'était
les micros des caméras des joueurs que
j'avais pas fermé alors je vais juste
vérifier
c'est vrai que la fait sur un nouveau
logiciel depuis plusieurs jours et j'ai
peut-être oublié
le micro pas de micro devant forest je
l'ai coupé
et aussi OK
donc parfait on est bien donc bonjour à
tous ceux qui viennent d'arriver donc on
a humé Arnaud Marius budinard et
personne
salut les gars
comment et les filles peut-être je dis
salut les gars mais les filles peut-être
oui à tous et à toutes et bienvenue à
tous et bien sûr n'hésitez pas ainsi
vous avez des questions
que ce soit des questions perso des
questions sur l'événement une question
sur les chéquiers sur ce que vous voulez
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à nous écrire
sachez aussi que on a 60 secondes de
délai par rapport à vous
par rapport au stream en fait quand vous
écrivez un message et ben on voit le
message instant
par contre quand on vous répond vous
avez la réponse une minute après donc
c'est un peu bizarre donc pour dialoguer
je sais que c'est un peu difficile mais
en tout cas n'hésitez pas les questions
ou des choses à dire etc c'est voyez par
exemple Kévin va participer au Top 16
très très bientôt je crois que c'est la
pleine prochaine ça commence donc ça
arrive bah au même titre que Jules
d'ailleurs
il sera stouf d'ailleurs et l'info du
moment parce que ça a été relayé dans le
chat on rappelle que que stouf il est au
bord du titre de mi il lui manque le
point hello donc il nous avait parlé à
la faveur d'une victoire contre un grand
maître et il est vraiment alors on va
pas de poisson mais on te souhaitait
depuis longtemps le meilleur et
maintenant tu es aux portes donc il y a
plus qu'à qu'à confirmer cela
prochainement mais c'est super on est
très content de la de ton retour au
niveau hello à ta juste valeur parce que
tu étais tombé mais pour mieux remonter
bravo à toi merci
une stratégie c'est une stratégie sauf
incroyable comme ça après quand tu
gagnes plus de points quoi c'est génial
mais alors le match retour contre Kevin
alors en fait on peut faire les gens on
peut si vous voulez me faire ce que vous
voulez mais en fait on a fait une partie
là déjà c'est mal passé il a dit bon on
fait pas on fait on fait match retour
bon allez la partie j'aurais préféré une
partie lente pour refaire mais
j'attendais qu'il était au hello dès que
tu auras ton titre
imaginez que quand on a quand on a fait
ce match en partie enfin en blitz sur
Internet et ben Kevin il a fini vidéo en
montrant la partie la commenter la
partie qu'on avait déjà en partie lente
une partie que vous avez 2184 hello
j'étais
[Musique]
la plus la plus grosse contre perte de
Kevin et de
pour situer en fait non dans le même
tournoi j'ai fait aussi la plus grosse
contrepert mais après le mec a été
confondu pour triche voilà bon
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en fait il
a fait une vidéo dire bon ok vidéo parce
que maintenant on va jouer en blitz on
va le battre et sauf que bon bah le
match public bah je l'ai gagné aussi et
donc maintenant bah si encore un match
retour mais combien de degrés de match
retour va y avoir on sait très bien que
le score ça va toujours être pareil
Kevin
crois pas je crois pas après en Bullet
il faut pas que je joue en Bullet parce
qu'on sait très bien que bon je suis je
suis léger dans d'autres registre là
faudrait que je fasse des concours de
puzzle rush c'est pas mal la puzzle rush
c'est pour moi j'ai compris ce fou
j'étais
[Musique]
dispo et en fait c'est toujours et qui
nous manque après on arrive pour
quelques screenshot com en même temps
bah tu vois disponibilité limité même
pour les streams chez com quand là
j'arrive je sors de cours comme tu le
sais à 20h45 je pars parce que j'ai pas
de Milton j'ai une vie bien remplie et
la prochainement tu sais on pouvait
streamer le Nord watch toi tu peux le
faire souffle et donc bah il y a le top
le Top 16 ok parce que c'est une belle
année pour toi ben dans lequel tu vas
jouer l'an prochain tu vas venir avec
avec ton équipe ouais c'est ça donc on
va vous regarder
[Musique]
moi je vais en tout cas je vais regarder
avec grand plaisir c'est une compétition
que j'adore parce que bah déjà tu
connais quasiment tout le monde toutes
les équipes et puis c'est hyper sympa et
puis en plus sachant que l'année
prochaine et Ben et ben je serai parmi
vous et ben c'est d'autant plus
intéressant en fait pour moi de regarder
parce que ben je me rappelle je suis
dans quoi j'ai dit ok bien sûr ça va
être comme ça etc donc ça va être ça va
comme je comprends tout à l'heure parce
que pendant l'épisode covid tu sais
certaines équipes avaient joué d'autres
non moi j'étais vraiment malheureux de
pas pouvoir jouer le top et c'est vrai
que depuis l'an dernier bah ça a repris
tout à fait normalement et c'est
vraiment la compétition par excellence
parce que tu peux jouer des des
superstars du jeu tu peux jouer mvl tu
peux jouer des joueurs comme ça parce
que même un VL qui a un super hello il
peut descendre sur des effets je vais
pas dire bas mais on va dire à 3e 4e
selon les les équipiers qu'il a mais
honnêtement on peut vraiment jouer du 27
je jouais vraiment des super joueurs en
top et c'est génial quoi
[Musique]
ils ont l'air ils ont l'air d'être prêt
on se demande même si ça n'a pas
commencé mais
entre qui va gagner le match entre
Dimitri Collard et Jules Moussa donc si
vous voulez parier au point de chaîne
c'est le moment normalement le chat va
être assez corpo non parce que logique
d'être assez Chauvin dans cette
situation
je sais pas pour toi tout on oublie
qu'il est français je le mets quand même
légèrement favori donc là normalement le
fait d'être sur chaise comme fr ben ça
doit faire pencher la balance
je les joueurs sont en train de jouer ou
pas on a l'impression qu'ils sont en
train de peut-être de jouer ce que je me
disais
mais assez bravo
alors vous avez la partie donc là on a
alors je vais vous mettre un jus là les
Noirs dans la première partie on va
mettre plus en bas tout le temps et
est-ce que on revient depuis le début de
boire un peu ce qui s'est passé dans
cette partie j'aime bien ce super de
faire ça
en un joueur qui a parlé de Collard je
sais pas qui c'est je sais pas si on
peut savoir qui c'est
[Rires]
je crois pas
alors
de quoi on était sur une défense Ruf
russe ou défense pétrole
normalement ce qu'on dit c'est que c'est
ultra solide ça te défense pétrole c'est
plutôt le jeu dans un premier temps pour
l'égalité mais au final la position est
légèrement déséquilibrée quand même plus
que légèrement d'ailleurs stuff au
niveau de la structure et une activité
plus en berne côté noir ce qui explique
peut-être le jugement donc on laisse la
jauge c'est les consignes c'est
l'autre
oui oui
alors ben écoutez
sans ordi sinon si c'est juste répéter
les coups de l'ordi maintenant l'ordi de
plus en plus fort en plus donc bon c'est
pas forcément hyper intéressant déjà la
jauge à titre perso je l'enlèverai bien
je trouve que les commentaires serait
beaucoup plus humain parce que même nous
en commentant d'avoir la jauge ça nous
donne une indication et ça peut même
fausser notre jugement bon voilà bon
après souvent il y a plus de spectateurs
qui aiment avoir la jauge pour
estimer la position avec fiabilité
moi j'ai j'ai fait
j'ai fait
/
et ça m'a ça m'a fait ça une prédiction
donc c'est ce que je vais faire
après je suis pas un expert à modo mais
j'ai fait
[Musique]
j'ai fait cela
bon en tout cas qu'est-ce qui se passe
ici
Jules peut manger un pion ainsi
que le fond en plus
c'est un peu chaud
beaucoup de choses à surveiller dans
cette position avec la dame de Jules qui
est finalement une dame qui exerce une
pression mais qui peut aussi se faire un
petit peu chahuter par pas mal de coups
par défaut trois c'est pas c'est pas si
facile que cela
j'aime bien pour toi parce qu'en fait
il y a plusieurs menaces qui peuvent
avoir lieu dans le sens bon si les
pièces s'échangent ici les noirs peuvent
avoir une position à peu près ok parce
qu'il voudra structure d'option ils sont
bien il y a aussi une menace si le pion
venait à partir il faut prendre F3 et
5 qui pourrait être une possibilité mais
attention qui est aussi à la fin de la
viande c'est promis cette donc c'est pas
si clair mais dans tous les cas ici la
dame défend le foot case noir et après
prise ici et ben le fou n'est pas en
prise si je commence par défaut au 3 ici
maintenant peut-être que si demain 5 il
peut y avoir prise ici avec d'apprendre
d'un point de 6
mais on sent que c'est pas très naturel
mais bon ça tient ça tient quoi
vient chahuter la dame est-ce que sur
damastron j'aurais pas C4 pour essayer
de profiter de notre pion en dessin qui
va être à la fois isolé mais avancé donc
pénible aussi pour le développement
d'une naturelle cavalier B8 en C6 sera
pas possible
il y a aussi oui c'est 4 pour amener le
cavalier en D4 dans des conditions
parfaites
que pour l'instant qui a validé quatre
faut vérifier peut-être qu'à valider 4
tout de suite a du sens sauf puisque
j'avais pas nécessairement vu mais on a
des idées de cavalier B5 donc avec des
cartes c'est plutôt pas mal aussi
à chaque fois pour vérifier ok difficile
donc tu veux faire un truc du style
prise et qu'elle V5 ouais c'est ça donc
soit on fait ça soit on joue C4 pour
cette idée là on a les deux choix sans
doute qui va assurer par ces quatre
parce que maintenant comme j'ai dit je
pense en fou prends des cinq ou si on
prend des cinq et puis après
kb5 on a damassis in extremis
heureusement
et on a on garde un pressing dans cette
position parce que même si on a un pion
faible en C3 sur le long terme à court
terme on a un très joli jeu de pièces en
fait ici donc
un peu ok ouais c'est pas simple pour
Jules mais je crois qu'il a pas trop le
choix il va devoir jouer dans ma proie
il me semble si je veux pas dans ma 3
ben j'ai l'impression que le fou des 6
va être en difficulté en partie exacte
qu'est-ce qui peut lui d'autre que dans
ma 3
[Musique]
peut-être un procès 3 bon c'est un petit
peu chercher les
l'idée de prise là c'est que j'ai
d'apprendre j'étais franc là mais bon
de l'autre côté et manger en C3 il y a
un peu tout en prise franchement ça
m'a pas l'air génial
[Musique]
on n'a pas envie mais après concrètement
il faut calculer
pour ça
dépend des 6 tu prends le cavalier
être concret quoi et
donc là je lui ai mal au temple
ça sera du sens après c'est un petit peu
difficile de
s'engager vers dedans sans réfléchir
parce que ça peut être foutu tout de
suite encore plus rapidement et
concrètement parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
cours à regarder sur dame prend ces
trois même foodécartes peut-être que je
peux prendre en F3 dans ces cas-là j'ai
pris F3 même ça existe des fois ça va
être des positions complètement folles
que je prends F et là du coup il faut
vérifier bien sûr les les éléments
tactiques côté
côté des
blancs est-ce qu'on peut vite amener une
tour en géant je crois que ça a l'air ça
a l'air à peu près ok parce que je suis
un peu lent à ramener mes places donc
finalement le coup de tour C1 paraître
mais il faut vérifier tout ça parce que
ce sont des calculs forcés qui amènent
une position
donnée hyper déséquilibré hyper complexe
donc
on est sûr de voir en cas d’âme français
3 faut vérifier aussi toujours les pions
prononcés 6 d'accord on Adam français 6
évidemment mais on va faire tourner
d'abord vraisemblablement la rendre que
tu donnais elle avait l'air assez
logique sauf étroit tour C1 et dame F6
pour rester au contact du
du Fou
concrètement il faut un truc si tu as
rien avec avec les Blancs bah écoute je
vais m'appuyer peut-être sur quelque
chose comme tout à l'heure je voulais
faire je vois que ça a joué mais il y
avait peut-être la possibilité de jouer
avant tout c'est un cavalier des quatre
ici là pour bien mettre le cavalier
empêcher ça
et avoir les thèmes avec avec tourcé 1
toujours les thèmes à cavalier B5
c'est pas mal souple
tu vois je sais pas mais 5 enfin tout
est compliqué en fait à chaque fois que
c'est n'importe quoi
[Musique]
parce qu'au final
tant que j'empêche ça bah écoute
qui arrive bon c'est chaud là ça
commence à être très très chaud
ça marche pas on voit que c'est assez
chaud il faut prendre je vais pas
rajouter ici
donc là il y a tout en privé il faut
calculer il faut 5 il faut calculer la
première fois
dans la dans toutes les complications
alors juste rapidement alors ce rôle on
va juste terminer cette vente là et puis
après on va les raisins on va essayer de
voir les deux on va essayer de voir les
deux juste d'un point F c'est chaud là
c'est super chaud on peut pas partir
alors qu'on n'a pas pu ce moment-là
parce que peut-être que en fait
peut-être que je l'ai perdu ou peut-être
que c'est pas voilà
bien sûr il a allumé le cavalier qui
peut être dangereux mais là les 10
octobre c'est un petit cadeau 5
et peut-être qu'il a le temps de réagir
réorganiser la pièce par exemple ça ça
et sur une prise tu fais quel exercice
et nul quoi
espérer
[Musique]
un peu désagréable à cause du pion à 7
malheureusement c'est un pas de chance
mais on voit tout racisme arriver et
avec une un problème concret
mais bon peut-être que je trouve ça vite
je peux bien sûr
que c'est une finale qui peut peut-être
être
envisageable il faut penser 5 juste
pour voir un peu ce qui se passe là
c'est un bouftou
et là
je sens
non comment tu veux là je suis là
oui
parce que je prends la tour tu manges là
je pense ouais j'arrive attends
[Musique]
parce que le pion C3 maintenant le
ressemble beaucoup plus
ok c'est pas forcément une bonne chose
mais d'un point F3 avait l'air quand
même pas mal
à manger concrètement et là faut être
précis là c'est important peut-être
qu'on peut jouer un coup calme style
tour des un
c'est vraiment un moment clé ouais
est-ce que tu connais rapidement ce qui
se passe chez intéressant
alors on suit comme deux Français
et on veut il a les Noirs aussi dans
cette partie à l'irrédafiruza
et alors on voulait refait en accélérer
si vous voulez un pour voir un truc
on donne le centre et on essaie de le
récupérer on le tapant le plus vite
possible donc tous ces quatre cavaliers
2 une des grandes lignes classiques
voilà et vous voyez en tout cas à la
dynamique de l'ouverture vous l'avez
compris facilement puisque c'est
vraiment on éclate le centre adverse et
du coup
bon j'ai un pionate de plus avec les
noirs
et c'est quoi le contre jeu réel bon
c'est le petit pion à chat qui tape qui
tape les rois quand même
mais l'échiquier se vide et c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour le camp qui
attaque normalement
tu échanges plus ça simplifie les choses
et écoute j'arrive pas à trouver le
qui qui veut être joué parce que si
trois prend un site il y a une
découverte mais c'est quoi la découverte
[Musique]
il a intérêt de trouver des ressources
et en fait c'est pas facile de trouver
les ressources à titre perso je manque
d'idées ici je trouve maintenant que on
voit clairement que les Noirs veulent
tout échanger pour s'octroyer une très
bonne finale alors souvent on dit aussi
qu'il faut dans ces cas-là commencer à
sentir le truc et commencer à jouer pour
l'égalité mais même ça essayer de
d'arranger un peu ma future finale bah
je vois pas donc
je sais pas du tout comment il va
comment il va jouer ça c'est très
créatif
c'est un peu long
[Musique]
non mais c'est dur c'est très très dur
peut-être là une extremis cavalier D5
pour jouer pour F4
tant pis je vais laisser mon crayon H1
je peux manger la chambre
évidemment c'est la même
[Musique]
c'est quelques entrées
ok mais en tout cas je je crois vraiment
en chance de à lire cette partie je
pense que
ça peut j'aime bien
c'était une des variantes parce que je
pensais à Tours C8 faut C8 tu sais
qu'elle va les D5 et tu prenais en H5 et
dames c'est un peut-être mais du coup
c'est un peu le même style de variante
alors donc tu me parlais un petit peu en
arrière
tu sais tout à l'heure je faisais ça
et c'était un peu bordélique j'arrivais
pas à trop à voir et je pense que c'est
l'idée de Fabiano mais dans le sens
inverse en fait
ça doit être plus précis alors pour une
raison qui m'échappe mais
d'un autre côté ben écoute je peux tout
je peux tout te changer
[Musique]
il faut prendre des 5 c'est la question
mais peut-être comprendre tout
simplement
hyper tendu
moi je ferais bien vous voyez on peut
peut-être faire archi interdire mais
même si on prend je suis pas sûr qu'il
puisse facilement te faire plaisir
donc là la chie c'est
H6 pour moi ça va pas cette position
je fais à chiche d'abord que tu as
proposé parce que je voulais le garder
pour après si tu veux jouer à 6 prises
c'est vraiment les problèmes donc ça
peut commencer à être un peu compliqué
alors il y a eu pour c'est un il y a eu
je prends un H5 alors lui
c'est bien je prends H5 il y avait des
dames et
je te faisais plein de trucs avec plein
de trucs en prises bon c'est pas encore
comment en prison c'est quand même tendu
il y a F6 qui peut tomber par exemple ça
ça mais le roi en H6 c'est qu'elle va
les prendre M6 qui fait fourchette
c'est pas dangereux là je prends H5 bah
écoute c'est un coup un petit peu j'ai
envie de dire
[Musique]
on fait le stream en espagnol ça j'ai
fait j'ai fait allemand bon je suis pas
fou en allemand mais j'ai fait allemand
donc pas une minute d'espagnol
normalement je peux pas te tromper non
plus
c'était quand même une décision
difficile pour les blancs est-ce que tu
fais le hg6 que tu avais proposé ou
est-ce que tu laisses le pion à H1 qui a
un pion bélier on va dire pour éclater
l'Europe noir mais on est dans une
pré-finale donc c'est beaucoup moins
grave que s'il y avait les tours sur
l'échiquet il y a quand même les pièces
attention il y a les dames il y a les
dames mais il y a encore un pion en 4
qui est
qui peut tomber
surtout on contrôle tout maintenant faut
bien finir avec avec les Noirs c'est pas
si facile quand même en pratique non
c'est pas simple parce qu'en fait tu
vois les pièces noires contre lequel pas
mal de cases d'entrée donc ça c'est déjà
bien c'est bon signe d'ailleurs Fousse
et 6 ça fait vraiment sens parce que
j'aimerais bien remettre ce fou par
exemple en D7 voilà je peux pas passer
par C8 voilà
contre elle est un peu plus de cases
quand on parle du loup
je pensais à cavaler ces 6 que je
trouverais de venir en B4 ouais mais
j'aimais bien contrôler la case
ou C4 là c'était bizarre enfin c'était
un peu difficile à calculer non mais tu
vois ça c'est bien moi j'aime beaucoup
ton coup en fait parce que c'est un coup
en fait ça montre bien que des fois il
faut pas se presser tu as une position
qui qui est tendue hein mais en fait les
Blancs ont pas grand chose à faire et
pas stresser juste tu peux améliorer
améliore tes pièces en amélioration des
pièces on en parle tout le temps c'est
le principe même de enfin de la
stratégie
c'est c'est important il faut toujours
penser à améliorer les pièces donc là
apparemment ce Kung fuy huit c'est un
gars raté des Noirs apparemment
bien joué après leur dire et vous voyez
que à les raisons n'a pas vu donc c'est
que c'est pas si simple c'est pour ça
que notre jauge des fois pour
l'appréciation et je vois pas j'étais en
train de chercher pourquoi X2 est une
gaffe et et ça c'était pas hyper
transparent souffle
peut-être que c'est pas grave cavalier
prend un chien mais ou alors simplement
H4 j'en sais rien c'est pas facile quand
même
pas trop trop l'idée mais il y a un truc
qu'on comprend pas en tout cas c'est
clair peut-être H4
c'est très dur comme décision parce que
il y a le problème de la rentrée de la
dame en C8 donc humainement
c'est pas le pré coupe en garde quoi
après là c'est un blé de ça ils ont plus
de temps la pendule donc ok même si
peut-être que il reste là il y a pensé
qu'on prend un quatre c'est possible
mais en fait en pratique il faut il va
défendre depuis en plus les noirs n'ont
pas d'entrée ici juste je sais que des
fois
en fait ils ont quand même l'entrée en
C8 mais qui n'est peut-être pas trop
grave mais quand même c'est un peu chaud
à chaque fois et d'ailleurs j'ai trois
c'est pour jouer dame C8 je pense tout
fin j'ai trois dames celui que oui pour
avoir des cartes pour le roi et aussi
pour rentrer la dame j'imagine
tu sais qui peut vriller vite c'est à
dire que sans doute que les noirs sont
mieux mais on a déjà eu des positions
comme ça en partie rapide et on sent
qu'à tout moment si on joue un coup très
imprécie nos droits peut prendre cher
[Musique]
problème peut-être
après c'est
content
j'ai toujours cavaler prendre H5
ou l'inverse bon c'est position en fait
mais tu as pas envie de rentrer dans ça
en fait tu as deux pions plus il faut
que je joue un peu solide et que tu
arrives à stable vous voyez il essaie de
stabiliser mais c'est pas facile la
petite menace dame c'est 8 c'est
vraiment un coup qui fait extrêmement
peur
c'est extrêmement difficile à gérer
psychologiquement parce que on est au
bord de maîtriser complètement cette
position et bien sûr j'aimerais faire
domestique 5 mais je pouvais pas à cause
du cavalier en 6
et c'est le ciel bleu alors oui
mais c'est un coup d'ordi et ça permet
cavaler un H5 on expliquait avant
en pratique c'est ça donne beaucoup de
jeux donc tu as pas envie de rentrer
là-dedans en fait voilà
les raisins il y a probablement pensé
mais juste en pratique avec peu de temps
la pendule tu vas essayer de défendre
tes pièces et pas rentrer dans toutes
les complications tu vois c'est juste
donc dans ma 3 c'est un coup rigolo pour
taper à 7 bien sûr dames C5 toujours que
pas de cavalier C5 bon est-ce que j'ai
pas le droit de jouer un coup basique de
A5 il a remis son club
plutôt
le tôt que tard il faudrait ramener
ses petits pions à défendre il y a
toujours des fourchettes pas reste-t-il
encore
les chèques sur l'instant rangée et
pendant ce temps-là peut-être essayer de
faire un truc
C4 un jour peut-être alors tant fou F7
celui de dame c'est 5
peut-être qu'à un moment donné tu peux
faire valoir
madame C8 quoi toujours pareil
c'est toujours l'idée de rentrer en 17
et du coup
on a laissé les valves depuis
alors il y a eu plein de jouets
à 5 il veut gagner un pays
très bien
est-ce qu'on passe rapidement sur revenu
de voir ce qui s'est passé
en train de dessiner son gars mais
attention c'est toujours bordélique et
Jules il est mal au temps et il a il a
un pion de plus mais bon c'est pas le
plus qu'on veut
ouais c'est une position difficile il y
a le roi qui s'est fait un petit peu
extraire
l'histoire mais tout c'est un OUI à peu
près ce qu'on avait dit j'ai trois tout
la ligne
pour D1 d'accord c'était et quel était
le garde manqué juste surtout on a vu
qu'il y avait une histoire de manquer
c'est dur ou
on
reprend des 5 derniers
c'est juste des appréciations de
l'ordinateur ok donc faut prendre des 5
et il a joué cette
on avait étudié cette même position sauf
mais il y avait pas les dames mais la
dame qui est forte en F3 c'est un
facteur aggravant c'est beau hein ce H4
H5 H6 pour déstabiliser le petit rock
retenez-le hein et puis empoisonné pour
les forts grand maître très utilisé
cette perception h puis on bélier
j'ai un peu peur du coup est-ce que je
peux jouer encore ah non
c'est un problème quand même OK
ça fait pas plaisir mais en fait moi je
pensais de faire ça explore ça je
pouvais faire ça pour défendre à ma tour
le problème en fait c'est que c'est ça
tu vas jouer 4
j'ai pas fou 5 malheureusement le foot
c'est pas par dessus la pièce elle
tourne C4 mais
fout des deux comme on trouve pas
[Musique]
c'est quoi les
c'est dur même Dame des trois dames B3
il y a plein de coups terribles qui sont
peut-être qui veut juste manger en des
deux et
là oui mais ça marche
très malin parce que maintenant on peut
plus bouger ouais
comme c'est 6 ou des deux mais on bouge
toujours plus
et là
ou des deux ça a l'air de gagner non
parce que tu peux pas manger là il y a
trois fois
beaucoup de problèmes mais Jules qui
avait 7 secondes à la pendule Jules qui
est de jouer
je pense que là le fou sera mal placé en
plus en des deux après tu reprends ces
quatre en plus il peut pas défendre
qu'il y a des menaces de maths en plus
vous voyez en plus
donc tout recarde fait sens dans cette
position pour continuer le harcèlement
qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu sur tout requin
de se rendre matin Dame des 8 dames des
4 ou des choses comme ça
bien sûr
pas loin de terminer là
un endroit qui va sortir ça n'a pas de
bon tout ça
c'est parti
comment on la joue
Dame des 7 me semble-t-il
[Musique]
par contre malheureusement
une bonne nouvelle pour
la dame elle est hyper loin moi je l'ai
raté
oui tu peux changer les dames des fois
aussi
tout en l'air donc il va bientôt
abandonner après roi des deux voilà
F8 c'est ça va être en plus là
c'est juste qu'il continue pour la forme
voilà ok ben écoute Jules tu perd la
première partie malheureusement
[Musique]
les raisins qui a toujours ces deux
pions de plus et là c'est une partie
vous en 15 secondes chacun c'est
c'est hyper compliqué et c'est utias
foot salut à toi
bienvenue à tous ceux qui arrivent sur
le chat à lui ACTA
compliqué salut à tous
ouais alors dame 17
on voit que sur seul quand joue pour
gagner il y a que les noirs avec les
deux pions de plus sauvegaff évidemment
mais vous comprenez ici qu'on est un
petit peu
en souffrance
on attire la dame en H1 puis après on
jouera G7 il y a plus rien
mais c'est casse gueule à gagner cette
histoire même la finale avec peu de
temps la pendule c'était pas sûr c'est
pas sûr attention on a vu on a vu les
raisins être un peu fébrile il va me
donner un pion là
il a maintenant lui
[Musique]
il y avait d'autres
sûrement complètement gagnant mais
maintenant il peut être perdant c'est à
deux doigts d'ailleurs que ça déconne
ouais attention là il peut gagner il
peut perdre si on peut tout voir sur roi
là il y a maintenant un coup avec dans
ma chambre
un roi H2 il y a du cavalier chaque
cavalier chèque c'est chaud
on voit la jauge qui qui vient descendre
tout en bas qui se passe au caballer là
il y a trois H4
F5 oulala on sent là on sent que ça va
pas le faire là ça va être mat
te
position de résultat tu rappelles sauf
quand je l'ai dit et voilà c'est
clair
chaud
de compétiteur parce que ce sont des
joueurs très forts qui aiment pas être
mal forcément mais ils assument ils
assument je pense que bien sûr à lireza
a beaucoup mieux joué cette partie mais
Fabiano a tenu le stand il a continué et
s'est battu a rendu la victoire d'aller
resa difficile au final va gagner c'est
ça c'est ça
en tout cas en tout cas de belles
parties donc là nos deux Français ont
tout le 2 perdu avec les Noirs donc ils
auront les blancs tous les deux contre
le même adversaire là d'ici 5 minutes
après après la pause et
avec obligation de gagner parce que
c'est en deux matchs si
les joueurs arrivent enfin si les
Français arrivent à gagner de la
pratique clé blanc il y aura un
départage qui te prend en Armageddon
donc on vous expliquera un petit peu
comment ça marche pour ceux qui ne
savent pas et si et ben les Français ne
gagnent pas partie et ben ils seront
éliminés de la compétition je vous
rappelle que pour être éliminé il faut
perdre deux matchs et là c'est le
deuxième match
qu'ils ont perdu
il a jamais été en mesure de gagner
cette partie à l'inverse à l'IRESA
forcément green bien dégoûté d'avoir
dominé autant à un super joueur comme
Fabiano pour ne pas réussir à le finir
et se faire voler le point entier parce
que un demi point il savait que c'était
toujours possible le pont entier c'est
vraiment dur parce qu'il avait des pères
pètes il avait
full tendu à trois résultats ouais bah
en fait le temps fait que même des
grands joueurs n'arrivent plus à
stabiliser quand les deux rois sont en
l'air en fait sauf bague avec 20
secondes dans la pendule c'est très
difficile
donc voilà bon nous on va partir en
pause enfin c'est pas que je veux partir
en pause c'est que on il y a beaucoup de
sponsors en fait dans cet événement et
on a le devoir et l'obligation de vous
faire passer des pubs
pendant cet événement donc on va partir
en pause pendant 5 minutes Kevin puis
après on reviendra pour suivre la
deuxième ronde de cette poule des
perdants à tout de suite
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec Kevin pour
cette deuxième ronde de
de
cette pour dépervant entre
carbona Fabiano donc on a la deuxième
partie qui vient de démarrer donc là
c'est Jules qui est des blancs en
espagnol et à lire les arts c'est une
quelque chose comme ça
elle était géniale et je voyais attaque
qui me disait comment les noirs auraient
dû jouer bah c'était très difficile avec
les quelques secondes qui restaient mais
il fallait stabiliser pas se faire
embêter le roi facile à dire quoi facile
à dire parce que c'était très chaud donc
là c'est un système qui est joué par par
alliésa tranquille pas de risque pas de
risque on est on va travailler cette
position
donc vraiment cool
donc là c'est la structure des pions
pendant
ces basiques aux échecs il y a le plan
connu F1 G3 fois 3D 5 mais il a passé
par B1 mais il y avait un plan assez
connu qui est intéressant parce que
l'objectif de cette position souffre
avec les pions pendant c'est un monde
jouer des cinq en force pour valoriser
le centre et c'est vrai que c'est pas
bête de ce plan thématique fois j'ai
trois fois H3 c'est le plan assez connu
pour placer le fou face à la Tour C8 et
alimenter des dessins ils ne sont pas
toujours jouable et les Noirs quant à
eux aimeraient échanger des pièces pour
fragiliser sur le long terme les pions
C4 et des quatre donc là on veut garder
les pièces et jouer fort et l'autre veut
anéantir le combat petit à petit par les
échanges de pièces comme dans le pion
isolé les pions pendant en fait
c'est le même principe
qui sont commeies ouvertes ça il faut
pas l'oublier et ce qui fait qu'en fait
les pions se défendre peuvent se
défendre entre eux et vous voyez que on
peut pas trop avancer parce qu'ils sont
bloqués par les pions à faire simplement
aussi c'est pour cela qu'en fait ces
pions
pas vraiment défendu par notre option et
sur le long terme peuvent être faibles
mais les blancs comme l'expliquer Kevin
doivent essayer de créer une percée pour
ouvrir les deux fous et attaquer le roi
noir par ça par exemple
donc salut je vais salut à toi
tourner des popotes pendant la pub et
puis joueur en tête de chargea ah tiens
un nom de la fin
alors j'ai vu que dinnera Wagner elle a
fait un super débutant
[Musique]
je suis un peu déconnecté mais
mais ouais c'était la joueuse bah maman
qui est en tête c'est une joueuse qu'on
ne connaissait pas trop on l'avait vu
déjà dans un tournoi féminin il y a pas
son mari elle arrive à s'installe en
tête
du Grand Prix féminin quoi c'est quand
même un gros gros niveau
donc c'est cool Wagner
donc une position qui va être qui va
être je pense que c'est tendu à l'irréda
qui
je pense qu'il va faire au lit
complètement est-ce que tu as la main
sur les points à mettre à jour
automatique
je te fais la remarque comme ça
vous savez un autre deux Français qui
sont inclinés lors de la première ronde
mais bon c'est encore long
je vais le mettre aussi pour
pour l'autre là haut
voilà désolé merci de me la faire
rappeler
et voilà vous voyez les noirs qui jouent
très solides et qui veulent échanger les
pièces
cavalier 17 comment est-ce qu'on peut
jouer avec les avec les Blancs ici
à h4a5 le problème c'est que pour
l'instant cette réaction elles sont pas
faciles à mettre en place
les coups comme Dame des trois
évidemment ça peut être une idée pour
alimenter des H4 H5 mais il faut faire
gaffe quand on met la dame en détroit de
pas se prendre une crasse des visas
partout exactement est-ce qu'une idée de
projets
8 de
5 comme ça peut être une idée voilà
c'est pour ça que je regardais tu vois
je me dis bon
non mais dans ma tête
je suis un petit peu à l'ouest il faut
pas écouter des fois encore une fois on
n'a pas
mais oui
[Rires]
une ancienne version d'ancienne version
il y avait des versions comme ça au tout
début qui jouait des bottes sur les
sites internet tu sais qui est joué
quand même en faisant des belles bêtises
donc on pouvait jouer à contre mais ok
là il faut essayer quelque chose à des
rois maintenant faut réussir à
transférer les pièces des tours étroites
3 des dames des trois pour la batterie
on a pas mal d'idées quand même
ok donc il a fait carrier projet 6 et
voilà ce thème avec un je me posais la
question stouf avec l'idée ou F3 dans ma
F3 et damage 4 est-ce qu'on avait le
droit de jouer ça
ça
gourmand la variété avec les Noirs
toutes les lignes donc
écoute pour
ce qui se passe dans le match
franchement c'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les raisins qui a perdu la
première partie et qu'il doit absolument
gagner la deuxième au moins quand j'en
joue comme ça et bien il met les choses
de son côté et il est en mode passion en
ligne donc
c'est pas un mauvais choix j'ai envie de
dire un pour lui faire ça
complètement bah c'est pas trop le style
de la maison
il envoie et Fabiano il répond présent
toujours pareil il est prêt
à tout jouer Fabien Noé et du coup c'est
pas impossible qui croque le pion
de toute façon en plus j'ai pas trop
envie de voilà j'ai mis envie de jouer
cavalier F6 ni de me prendre à chacun
il me prend une cavalier G5 donc par
l'émulation tu as envie de l'équation
au moins une pièce tu manges un pion et
tu dis vas-y prouve montre-moi
montre-moi ce que tu calcules quand pour
vérifier que c'est pas vraiment très
mauvais mais je le vois bien prendre
pareil
est-ce que tu veux aller voir ce qui se
passe chez lui là ouais c'est cool
ce que nous fait Jules elle est blanche
donc alors attends c'est pas ça un truc
là je vais prendre un petit peu au début
donc c'est une expérience
bon tout ça c'est très théorique sauf
pour l'instant on intervient assez peu
donc là vraiment c'est du grand grand
classique les deux joueurs connaissent
parfaitement et ce qui est assez rigolo
c'est que sur ce H3 c'est déconseillé de
prendre un F3 parce que ça ça crée un
énorme centre blanc
mais c'est étonnant qui connaissent pas
donc peut-être qu'il la joue
en partie
rapide cette variante Collard pour
essayer de gagner parce que le roi blanc
est quand même un petit peu fragile
alors
à cause de je prends F3 là vous voyez
c'est intéressant de voir ça parce que
au final il faut tenir donc
on va réussir donc là il a joué B4 et
puis il joue F4
qui est fondamental parce que c'est on
voulait faire je prends F3 pour venir
défendre l'option E5 avec la paire de
fou maintenant c'est une position qui
est casse gueule vous le voyez bien
donc
[Musique]
moins bien en tout cas encore une fois
dans cette situation de match Jules
cherche ce type de position donc donc
voilà et oui
carvana il est dans 92
devant moi que la génération
cariacine mvl Carlson seulement 90
avec un dame G4
il fallait regarder à 5 aussi
et voilà c'était pas possible
mais bon oui
tout comme toi sauf avec des idées créa
quand même
des fois j'arrive pas à résister mais
j'ai changé un peu
mon style moi beaucoup moins G5 qu'avant
[Musique]
non mais peut-être si ça va être joué
la position le roi c'est vrai que le roi
et
il va le placer ici comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait jouer avec les Blancs ça fait
pas de mal
peut-être
mais là concrètement il faut il faut
trouver une solution alors attention on
a toujours un damas-5 peut-être
maintenant pour pour faire quelque chose
la pression un peu bizarre
donc on peut imaginer que Dimitri
Collard ça réussit à surprendre Jules à
la faveur d'une ligne douteuse mais qui
joue là parce que il sait que finalement
dans une partie rapide cette idée
douteuse dans une partie lente se
transforme en idées hyper intéressante
quand l'adversaire est obligé de jouer
des coups assez rapidement
on voit pas vraiment pourquoi
l'ordinateur est si confiant avec les
Blancs parce que
les Noirs ont réglé pas mal de problèmes
ils ont perdu les cases blanches c'est
le la concession énorme qu'ils ont
réalisé mais bon sinon ça va quand même
plutôt fort le centre aussi appartient
un peu plus au blanc mais attention à F6
qui viendrait rebattre les cartes
pas facile
j'ai perdu la caméra de Colars je
pensais qu'il pouvait déconnecter en
fait non et là bienvenue
et puis bon je crois que Jules on voit
qu'il commence à réfléchir un peu plus
c'est que c'est pas si simple pour lui
ça y est tourner un il a déclenché
c'est vraiment le coup logique de
pression ce qu'on fait pas tout
simplement tour à D8 sauf pour pour
gérer cela et attention peut-être après
un fou B3
on met la pression en force sur sur D5
donc peut-être qu'il y a des idées dans
ces positions de D4 directement à des
cartes peut-être x 4
donc j'ai l'impression qu'il faut faire
tout rat des 8 d'abord un souffle
nous laisse une main
que mon micro est faible mais pourtant
mon micro il est juste devant moi
et je t'entends parfaitement mais ça va
pas t'aider
mais je pense que depuis le début
personne ne m'a dit que mon son avait un
souci donc peut-être que le problème
vient de toi zamites à Monsieur zami
excusez-moi
je sais pas si ça vient de moi aussi ça
vient de toi est-ce que dans le chat on
peut nous dire
si mon fond est bon si mon fond est pas
bon ce qui se passe et Augus bah c'est
compétition sur le site chescom
le championne chaise tours voilà et
voyez que c'est la chaise kit Cup parce
que pour ce cycle du champion de chaise
tours les sponsors ils font du naming de
tournoi on peut dire ça et
s'approprie les événements donc
tu as vraiment
pas mal de meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
alors je dis pas mal parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui participent à une autre
compétition en présentiel
mais en tout cas tu as beaucoup des des
meilleurs mondiaux qui sont quand même
présents on a cité
jumeaux Sart et Dimitri collards
aujourd'hui mais de l'autre côté tu as
Fabiano Caruana et à l'IRESA firuggia
qui sont
vraiment tout le temps dans le top 10
maintenant à lireza c'est installé en
tout cas
et carwana il a été numéro deux mondial
vraiment avec le record de Hello récent
mise à part Magnus Carlson voilà
apparemment on entend bien
donc c'est je sais pas je sais pas
peut-être que tu as un casque monsieur
invite aussi que des fois
[Musique]
ouais j'ai pas l'impression que le
problème mais après c'est difficile des
fois de voir on peut pas s'écouter en
même temps que qu'on se parle avec stouf
donc on peut pas écouter le stream de
chez nous voilà
si on a joué des cartes directement sous
via les fous E4 qui était très pénible
donc des cas c'est la réaction normale
dans cette position on veut un moment
donné je sais que
peut-être qu'il peut jouer ici
au 4
aussi
pour le 4 faut calculer des prends ces
trois souffles je sais pas trop ce que
ça donne
ouais c'est chaud
je reste sur la colonne
et
du coup c'est très compliqué
ça a l'air intéressant j'aime bien
j'aime bien pour toi
mais je pense qu'il faut que je décre je
pense que si tu veux pas des cartes et
ben je vais réussir à m'installer avec
Caval et B3 ou 3 et prendre le contrôle
de la case des 4 et je pense qu'une fois
que je suis en décape et ben j'ai une
position qui est assez sympa avec les
avec les Blancs oui c'est une belle
rupture bien sûr si les blancs arrivent
à stabiliser ce stuff le flou blanc va
parler pour toute la partie par contre
je me pose une question tu sais il y a
aussi cette histoire de F6 à gérer
est-ce que F6 on le gère avec Damas 5 en
force bah tiens on va le savoir voilà on
va savoir très vite deux réactions
c'était les deux réactions on va que des
quatre est-ce qu'il faut jouer de D4 où
est-ce qu'il faut jouer F6
donc là je fais de la machine c'est roi
G1
et je me disais quoi
[Musique]
mais je sais pas où je vais l'enlever tu
vois c'était des fois on a des problèmes
qu'on veut faire un truc
ça mais si tu avais joué dans machine si
tu avais plus ce truc là parce que
j'avais tourné en fait qui me naçait
on a l'impression qu'on laisse
s'échapper le roi mais en fait c'est
pour ramener la tour sur échec et là je
sais pas rouage 2 j'aimais bien ton coup
là je sais pas ce qu'on joue est-ce
qu'on peut sortir avec un dame F5 et
puis après on essaie de fuir avec le roi
en tout cas il a joué il a vu dommage 5
et Collard ça a répondu F5 tempo
en train de regarder donc il a pas mis
longtemps à avoir peur sans doute et
maintenant ben ok l'option F5 va bloquer
un peu le foot enfin la paire de fou
d'ailleurs des blancs qui lui qui a pas
le plus F4 et lui il est bloqué derrière
l'option F5 mais dans l'entreprise
on a plus F6 surtout c'est ça la
déception
qui était gênant et maintenant il faut
réussir
quand même
B3 quand même
oui simplement car elle est C3 on a le
temps de le jouer
non ça a pas l'air génial ça
donc
des cartes devraient arriver même si ça
ouvre à nouveau les cases blanches par
exemple fou B3 échecs mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on gère à peu près la
crise
j'arrive pas
peut-être que je peux juste manger en B3
mais bon pas satisfaisant quoi
qui est un mauvais coup apparemment
selon l'ordinateur vous pensez que des 4
était le bon coup
et maintenant c'est que si la tour D1
sera active on pouvait penser à cavalier
B3 aussi pour endiguer cette poussée des
quatre il a préféré faire cavalier F1
maintenant des cas de toute façon est
difficile à jouer c'est ce qui doit se
dire
difficile à le rayon touréen dans le 17
et en même temps qu'est-ce que je joue
sur des 4
concrètement et voilà c'est ça c'est que
c'est peut-être quand même possible
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici peut-être
x 4 x 2 il y a toujours des trois c'est
dur à jouer quand même ouais x 4 ou B2
peut-être
est-ce que j'ai le droit c'est pas sur
foubet de il faut vérifier deux trois
autour des deux tours D1 tu sais pour je
voulais gagner en force le pion
ce qu'on peut faire là
ouais donc x 4 x 2 et juste je vérifie
ce qui est pas parti C3 une une
[Musique]
une surprise mais à tour des sets prise
B2
et
tours
c'est toujours un peu frustrant pour
Jules parce que là il doit donner
en tout cas on n'a pas vu de grands
coups mais je pense qu'il aimerait bien
voir cette position et pas être obligé
de donner son fou merveilleux en C2
puisque c'est le fou qui circulait sur
tous les giclés
rapide chez
Ali résa il s'est passé plein de choses
chez Ali resa et il a ou c'est une
partie compliquée il a une tour avec la
paire de fou contre une dame et trois
pions
c'est hyper tendu hyper tendu mais les
pions c'est des pions
c'est ça peut être chaud
alors rapidement parce qu'il s'est passé
un tas de choses là on fait la fin
d'accélérer
il a fait ce qu'on avait dit
oui c'est ça et bien senti le coup vous
savez pas c'est comment les noirs
voilà ça c'est vraiment accéléré waouh
d'une complexité atroce on va passer le
détail mais vous voyez le matériel sur
des équilibrés
OK
noire c'est pour ça que la jauge penche
côté des Noirs mais c'est une position
très intéressante à jouer avec les
Blancs honnêtement je l'avais pour la
première fois je me demandais qui joue
pour le gars stouf ouais bah écoute les
deux ont l'air intéressant parce que
même là même un tour bien pour B7 si il
est peut-être tours ces deux sources et
7 alors pas mal
il faut venir taper adversaire
[Musique]
trop trop loin ben j'ai des menaces de
contre jeu le KT F5 aussi alors
c'est vrai que
4 et ben ça
ça
avec le noir mais ça laisse aussi des
cases
mais même le jour où tu auras ça dans 20
c'est pas mal aussi non
et si je bouge mon fou
je me suis dit où tu le bouges
parce que là
un peu vicieux comme d'hab 9 7
pour vérifier évidemment mais
avec une tour
on sent
aussi une idée est-ce qu'on peut jouer
un petit fou étroit à essayer de
replacer un peu avec les pièces et
essayer de sur le long terme pousser le
plus on imagine si mon pion arrive à
s'activer
dans une position comme ça mais ça va le
jouer sûrement à cause à cause aussi du
temps c'est à dire que c'est une
position hyper casse-gueule comme tout à
l'heure on sait que déjà les deux
minutes vont bientôt être croqués de
chaque côté et que ça va jouer
un peu à la loterie j'ai envie de dire
cette position parce que c'est hyper
chaud quand même tour à trois normal ça
va être chaud
c'est de prendre tous les risques et les
raisins donc mais écoute je préfère
quand même les blancs
c'est moins dans le brillant et de voir
que que sur le coup brillant
ok ok
il a juste il a juste laissé
le coup en prise bah écoute les raisins
qui qui a fait
match compliqué il avait une grosse
partie avant
en fait mais il a gaffé
c'était super des parties
donc là
il faut absolument qu'il gagne cette
partie sinon il sera éliminé
tout de même que
à la faveur de sa meilleure activité de
pièces et d'une meilleure structure
est-ce que ça va être suffisant pour
gagner c'est pas dit
ce que je dis meilleur structure de
pions pour le Pione 5
mais il y a quand même toujours le pion
F4 et sur le long terme bon on sait pas
comment ça peut devriez ce genre de
position je trouve que c'est quand même
plus sympa il y a ça il y a la colon g
aussi protégé
vers et meilleures un peu pourri ici
et du confortable après ça reste un bide
ça ils ont deux minutes contre 2 minutes
30 c'est avec trois secondes d'impriment
et juste un peu mieux et je la Cleveland
qui va devoir gagner c'est obligé
alors cavalier 7
c'est assez logique
pour essayer de liquider un souffle et
ouais les Noirs veulent essayer de
bras pas mais un truc comme ça
avec mon PC protégé
c'est pas sûr du tout mais c'est vrai
que j'aime bien quand même
position Blanchon peut-être pas là je
perds
on a un petit pressing est-ce que ça va
gagner avec le roi faible quand même
mais bon on a le pion E5 donc en tout
cas il y a encore matière à travailler
ouais il est il est mieux
il est mieux et
voilà
il faut que je le vide aussi parce que
ça peut
ça peut être chaud donc le gagnant de ce
match
jouera en demi-finale de la poule des
perdant contre Fabiano carvala voilà qui
vient de battre à lireza
la première c'est une partie hyper
compliquée ou à lireza était
complètement gagnant puis c'est maté et
la deuxième partie c'était très
compliqué aussi à irréel a donné une
pièce en un donc
cet événement
tu as juste au fait rentre dans les
complications en juin ils ont pas froid
aux yeux très courageux comme tu le
disais tout à l'heure en espagnol X5 les
aussi
et ce qui est un peu qui gâche le
suspense c'est que on voit que la jauge
a dit oui donc
sans doute une très bonne décision et
c'est vrai qu'il a pas trouvé comment
son adversaire et profiter il était en
semi bluff Dimitri Collard sans doute
puisque on voit qu'il réfléchit il a mis
la pression à la faveur du temps en
disant bah vas-y tu es cap ou pas cap
d'aller prendre en C7 et de jouer X5 vu
la réfléchis à dit oui cap et maintenant
comment même si les pièces sont très
bizarres chez Jules comment je fais pour
l'embêter bah c'est pas facile
question bizarre mais attention et
OK
la logique qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire G5
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
des des petits tricks
je peux avoir peut-être cavalu aussi oui
c'est ça
j'ai un peu du mal à comprendre là ce
qui se passe
non mais il a une minute il a joué vite
et sans doute maintenant il est foutu
avec le fouet 3 peut être pas mal son G7
moi j'aime beaucoup
il est il est juste en train d'essayer
de sauver sa poubelle et il faut que
Jules serre les boulons serre la vis
pour que ça lui échappe pas
mal aussi
ça ça peut taper de partout
c'est quasiment
quasiment la fin elle est jule
il a 40 secondes et son adversaire une
trentaine donc ça va c'est ok
pas de raison que ça lui échappe
gagné sur deux gaffes je dis pas qu'il
m'arrive pas alors ça je surtout la
première archi dominée et la deuxième
pas bien après oui il est solide et il
fallait le battre mais bon c'est juste
un peu dommage le dénouement bah de la
première comme la deuxième parce que la
deuxième promettait avec la paire de fou
tu sais stouf d'être hyper intéressantes
avec le matériel très déséquilibré c'est
les parties très créatives un peu déçu
du dénouement
la du résultat c'est surtout la la forme
canaliser 6 cavalier des cinq encore
plus fort
la chaussette
peut-être pour la partie
au revoir merci au revoir
et là c'est alors plus quasiment j'ai
besoin quand t'as pas de coup c'est la
pièce et il y a pas un coup de dames
il y a tout
c'est fini c'est complètement terminé et
s'abandon abandon Jules qui qui égalise
dans ce match donc du jour jilky quand
même très propre bravo Jul qui qui va
réussir à forcer un
armagidon alors l'armée pour ceux qui ne
savent pas comment ça se passe est-ce
que tu connais toi la la formule en cas
d'armage
et tu m'en as parlé de de cette formule
tu sais avec le jeu des enchères c'est
ça c'est ça en fait il y a des enchères
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait les deux
joueurs vont écrire à l'arbitre le temps
voyez là on va Collard qui réfléchit je
pense qu'il réfléchit à ça à savoir quel
enchères il veut
pour savoir parce que l'Armageddon en
fait c'est une seule partie qui va avoir
lieu et en cas de nul les Noirs se
qualifient et en cas bon si un victoire
qui gagne nul la noire se qualifie mais
les Noirs ils ont moins de temps à la
pendule ça veut dire qu'en fait ça va du
chaos donc là il y aura 15 minutes pour
les blancs quoi qu'il arrive 15 minutes
plus 00 secondes par quoi et les noirs
et ben ils vont avoir le temps qui vont
proposer donc en fait chaque joueur va
écrire l'arbitre un temps qu'il soit
avoir avec les noirs et le joueur qui
aura mis le temps le plus bas gagnera
l'enchère ça veut dire qu'on a vu on a
vu avant-hier je sais plus qui c'était
je crois qui sait c'était un Furious
Jack contre Collard d'ailleurs collars
l'avait mis neuf enfin quasiment 10
minutes je crois
et et vous avez mis 8 minutes 25
tu vois et en fait il voulait il voulait
vraiment les Noirs huit minutes contre
15 donc c'est un berserk
tout ça pour avoir pour avoir le noir
absolument c'est quand elle est noire et
ben tu peux faire nul et 8 minutes et
ben tu as quand même le temps de voir un
peu ce qui se passe dans la partie mais
c'est vrai quand même que 8 minutes
c'est ko c'est quand même pas énorme non
plus donc c'est une stratégie aussi
d'avoir les blancs parce qu'on est un
puncher ben là on voit est-ce que
Dimitri collards veut à nouveau les
Noirs alors qu'il a perdu qu'avec les
blancs il a été vraiment plus à l'aise
on voit que les deux joueurs ont réussi
à mettre la pression quand ils ont eu
les blancs donc c'est pas si facile
comme décision souffre ouais c'est ça
donc là je suis dans le
dans le
[Musique]
s'appelle le slack là de l'événement on
va nous dire dans un instant ce qui se
passe au niveau des
paris c'est les paris de temps donc pour
l'instant bah là je vois sur le chat
on fait une pause d'abord
ok
ils vont nous donner le temps dans
peut-être que nous on profite aussi pour
faire pour balancer un petit peu les
pubs
voilà d'ailleurs je vais vous montrer un
petit peu bon donc il faut que je vous
montre par rapport au stream
vous savez que Magnus Carlsen un nouveau
partenariat donc ça je vais vous le
montrer d'ailleurs attendez je vais
faire les choses différentes je vais
aller vous chercher les choses vous
allez voir ça va être plus sympa on est
sur la partie de de Jules je vais les
mettre là ici voilà
et je vais le mettre aussi tu en es un
je vais vous montrer un petit peu le
partenariat de Magnus et c'est la marque
Puma donc ils ont sorti des chaussures
qui sont franchement assez cool elles
sont sympas donc si vous voulez gagner
plein de points et l'eau et ben je vous
invite à vous procurer ces chaussures là
les chaussures de Magnus là elles vont
faire du bruit surtout tu les as acheté
déjà est-ce que tu as une tu es inscrit
au prévente ou pas encore mais mais je
suis sur le coup regardez un je vous
montre la photo Magnus avec sa marque
Puma et ses chaussures
voilà et j'ai une autre photo qui a
assez sympa franchement elles sont pas
mal moi j'aime bien
est-ce que tu as déjà eu des chaussures
Puma d'ailleurs resto
bonne question je pense que oui il va
falloir longtemps
et donc voilà en tout cas c'est
intéressant de voir que une marque comme
Puma s'intéresse aux échecs donc voilà
si vous êtes intéressé vous savez un
puma Magnus les chaussures sont en vente
donc je vous invite à aller
comme Magnus
Usain Bolt aussi qui est partenaire avec
Puma donc courir comme Usain Bolt et
jouer comme Magnus aux échecs bah c'est
pas mal voilà c'est facile excusez-moi
les chaussures apparemment donc
c'est très mal passé pour pour fearuja
qui AGA fait en fait il a fait deux
super parties et c'est hyper intéressant
mais dans la première bah il a gaffé une
partie qu'il avait dominé de A à Z dans
la deuxième partie extrêmement
compliquée ça promettait d'être beau
c'était tour de fou contre la dame et
quelques pions du coup c'est une
position très déséquilibrée et bah il a
regafé une pièce en un coup donc fin de
fin de circuit pour lui des fêtes
et alors attends je vais faire ça donc
oui donc j'ai la j'ai bien
la
confirmation que
il y a une pause encore et il y a encore
6 minutes de pause
avant de savoir quels sont les
les temps des joueurs et la petite
partie donc en patienter on va mettre
une petite page de pub vous savez que
j'ai plein de pubs à vous montrer donc
on a vu la les pubs de de R6 tout ça et
maintenant on va mettre d'autres pubs
vous allez voir aujourd'hui
donc je vous dis à tout de suite allez à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus Kevin qui est là
aussi alors j'ai les temps je l'ai tend
de
les enchères et je vais vous assurer que
les deux joueurs voulaient avoir
les blancs je pense
au vu des parties c'est pas illogique
normalement les joueurs préfèrent les
noirs avec ce que tu as expliqué le fait
de pouvoir faire nul mais il n'y a pas
que ça alors je le dis par rapport au
temps par rapport au temps qu'on me
posait parce que généralement celui qui
veut activer les noirs et ben il va
quand même
s'avancer un peu au niveau du temps par
exemple Collard 50 il avait joué contre
contre
Armageddon il avait joué en il avait mis
un peu moins de 9 minutes je crois et là
il est quand même monté à 9 minutes 3029
et Jules par contre il a mis 10-47 alors
10-41 tu peux être sûr que
Collard il va jamais
il va jamais mettre 11 minutes quoi
voilà beaucoup bien sûr donc en fait vu
avec son 10,47 il était très content ça
c'est clair donc donc voilà Jules allez
blanc et à l'obligation de gagner encore
une fois donc bien sûr commande
ecolarse peut se permettre de faire nul
donc peut-être voir un collar ce qui va
rajouter la même chose mais qui va
peut-être changer son mais il a raté
donc là vous voyez un escort ça va être
un un
et bien sûr malheur à Jules s'il ne
gagne pas Julie en obligation de gagner
et
comme là il vient de le faire une fois
il peut le refaire
bien sûr la partie était très chaude et
puis bon on mangeait blanc quoi son
destin un peu entre sa main c'est quand
même assez mal passé
donc c'est compliqué quand même comme
choix est-ce que tu veux les les blancs
mais de pouvoir gagner absolument parce
que tu veux les noirs et te dire bon je
peux jouer pour faire nul
c'est pas évident parce que les Noirs
15 minutes pour pour Jules contre 97 et
c'est du chaos
c'est du chaos donc
il y a pas de temps
jamais de temps pour sa compétition là
alors
c'est reparti
peut-être qu'il a regardé à la pause
c'est possible on est pendule bouge pas
la pendule bouge normalement
Mister Hansen
tu regardes bien
et quoi
réfléchir un petit peu ben c'est quand
même il y a 5 minutes d'avance à la
pendule et 5 minutes d'avance et ben je
vais pouvoir peut-être l'utiliser pour
essayer de mettre la pression quand même
et
faire des meilleurs coups donc c'est
quand même assez déséquilibré c'est
compliqué Jules doit absolument gagner
mais il a plus de temps à la pendu il
peut mieux jouer
mais en cas de nulle et ben Jules
intéressant intéressant
Dame des 7 jouets ou développement
normal donc là
évidemment oui
donc si finalement la partie est arrêtée
les pendule sont arrêtées aussi donc
c'est la logique yes Mister là c'est
reparti même ouverture mais moins de
Gamble côté Collard beaucoup plus nature
la cavalier B3 à la logique ici Tourer
aussi
ouais on doit améliorer nos pièces avec
les Blancs
très clairement
deux un peu aussi être une idée avec les
pièces qui sont en prises en face
les joueurs ils ont la même
problématique améliorer les pièces
peut voir le fou au stade se remettre en
D6 la tour a en E8
déplacement facile et peut-être aller
chercher la case F4 à un moment avec un
cavalier
ou vide améliorer voilà ça permet
automatiquement ouais tout à fait les
joueurs vont
regarder quel est le setup de pierre qui
est le plus engageant la seule petite
réflexion peut qu'on peut avoir sauf
c'est ce qu'on peut refaire cavalier B3
qui a des cartes qui fait sens qui
interdit en plus fou c'est 5
momentanément ou le passage par F1 mais
je vois pas trop là la raison j'ai trois
c'est une case dans l'espagnol mais pas
dans cet Espagnol ouverte cavalier 1 E3
n'a pas plus de son j'ai l'impression
donc kb3 par défaut on peut aussi
regarder les petits A4 pour aller
titiller la structure d'option alors que
la tour à 8 vient de partir est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée trois ça a l'air
plus naturel la vallée
qui est la structure et puis tu vois
avec la le cavalence ici c'est un peu
mal placé un devant c'est le fond aussi
si tu as envie qu'un autre un Cavalaire
et c'est intéressant parce que ce plan
cavalier enfin c'est un plan qui est
hyper pneumatique
plein plein plein de italienne mais
quand la position elle est ouverte et
ben c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
parce que là on peut se faire attaquer
de plein de manières il y a un fou qui
pourrait venir nous manger il y a un
Caval qui pourrait venir en E4 par
exemple aussi un jour empêcher cavalier
3 et en fait
jouer actif avec les Noirs peut vraiment
lui poser des problèmes dans cette
position je suis pas sûr que cette
plante qui avait F1 soit viable ici qui
avait les pétrole alors beaucoup plus
naturel et oui espagnol fermé ou
italienne cavalier F1 kg 3 parce que ce
sont des positions bloquées généralement
où on maîtrise le centre en tout cas
là c'est pas le cas c'est ouvert au
centre donc on a pas le temps de faire
les manœuvres et il a préféré cavalier
F1 alors ça c'est intéressant parce que
c'est pas le coup naturel mais comme il
réfléchissait bon évidemment on pouvait
s'attendre à quelque chose du style il y
a les cavaliers G5 aussi et puis il y a
la protection du roi aussi il est fou
prend H3 et sont toujours présents donc
et aussi un jeu le fameux fou G5 avant
pour éliminer une cavalier et attaquer
le pion en dessin et une fois que
j'arrive à Angers 3 il y a cavalier G5
aussi hein ça peut être un thème motif
non il y a la pression sur un peu toutes
les cases blanches sur la diagonale
non c'est ça c'est intéressant
cavalier ça paraissait pas si naturel
que ça tout à l'heure mais encore une
fois après bon
une fois
et voilà ce qui
réfléchit ça fait quasiment 40 secondes
qui réfléchit
on voit quand même qu'il avait peur pour
son fou justement le problème posé par
Jules là ennuyer et du coup il décide de
jouer fou F5
pour enlever ce fou aussi ce qui était
peut-être à moins bonne pièce un souffle
ouais c'est ça c'est logique en fait de
s'occuper de sa moins bonne pièce c'est
l'urgence de la position voilà pourquoi
elle fait ça
elle a pendule
et son insert avait 9 minutes 29
exactement donc ça fait quand même cinq
minutes trente d'avance
je n'appe que 4 mais bon ça reste quand
même beaucoup de temps et il faut qu'il
utilise pour essayer de mettre la
pression et jouer des bons coups obtenir
un avantage donc pour l'instant Collard
ça dépend c'est 2 minutes 20 dans cette
partie
et
ouais c'est bien ça donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir ici est-ce
qu'on peut voir un fou F4 peut-être
j'aime pas trop me mettre en vis-à-vis
d'être fou ou trois et plus logique avec
cavaler des casses
3 sont les coordida quand même peut-être
Dame des trois aussi qui est quand même
assez logique ouais on sort les piotes
tout dépend et d'armes des trois ça
permet de convoiter la case F5
maintenant comment et bien jouer pour le
A4 aussi je trouve très intéressant très
intéressant
ce côté magique puisque la tour n'est
plus placée en a 8
maintenant est-ce qu'on crée un fou
c'est 5 c'est une question à se poser
35 grand mot mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment embêtant de voir le le fou
débarquer sur cette case c'est tout ce
que Jules va devoir calculer Dame des
trois fousser 5 fougères 5 peut-être
pour mettre la pression
et Dame des trois jouets peut-être ouais
c'est ça la partie
que le foot 15 blanche des noirs est
parti donc ça paraît assez logique de
venir de venir les contrôler où j'ai 5
années c'est un coup candidat mais
maintenant
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a vu sur cavalier
F5 ah oui attention parce que pour
l'instant ma tour E1 je fais d'abord
prendre peut-être en à 8 ah oui mais
peut-être c'est pas si simple
tu veux faire et surtout prends un 8
cavaliers F5 ce que je voulais faire et
peut-être il y a cavalier E5
qui est bien énervant parce que le fou
sortirait peut-être de c'est compliqué
déjà rien que cette petite variante
quand même c'est une position on sent
qu'elle peut s'aplanir à tout moment
donc là les Noirs retrouver quand même
une disposition de pièces sympa au foot
ici j'ai l'impression que c'est bien
joué moi j'aime bien poser ça quoi je
pensais
et si je simplifie maintenant avec juste
vous prolonger 3 souffre avec l'idée de
dire que
quand même
dans cette position là je peux mettre
mon cavalier en E4 ça a l'air quand même
cool pour
pour jouer au moins pour pour l'égalité
aux échecs et ben en fait oui plus dans
son corps plus les nuls arrivent en fait
si les joueurs ne remettent pas de
fautes et qui arrivent à jouer à une
belle partie en fait ça fait très très
souvent nul hein
parce qu'il y a plus d'erreurs commises
mais plus d'effort plus la nul est
possible ça veut pas dire que ça finit à
chaque fois pas du tout mais il y a
beaucoup plus de nul c'est pour ça que
là avoir les Noirs d'un chemin comme ça
c'est pas stupide du tout façon
en plus c'est à ce niveau là ils savent
à un moment donné tu as une position qui
est solide etc ils vont savoir ne pas la
perdre donc c'est
intéressant
je trouve une solution là en tout cas
peut-être qu'elle
revient tout simplement j'ai fait mon
boulot
j'ai contre la cage G5 attention quand
même aux dames G6 mais peut-être que là
encore dans F7
il y en a boutique
là tu as raison souffre
mais il y a eu j'ai 5
alors
mais c'est un des thèmes de la position
bravo à lui attention parce que
faut toujours regarder les tours prend
le cadre dans ces positions
évaluer donc là
je pourrais avoir la main un moment
voilà et à la fin quand tu fais tout
reprendre c'est ça je pense qu'il faut
faire je vais prendre F4
pas de laisser ton four
et mon cavalier j'espère que j'ai trois
ça c'est sûr
voyez comme c'est compliqué
[Musique]
quand même pas mal sa position il y a
plein de trous autour de moi
il y a d'un point des 5 échecs avec ton
conquête en tout cas c'est l'idée de
Jules mais l'ordinateur n'aime pas du
tout il met un point d'interrogation
est-ce qu'il y a pas un cavalle c'est 50
intermédiat dans le
jardinules sont les plus intéressantes
ça dépend je dirais de l'ouverture parce
que des fois tu as des nul assez
soporifiques et des fois tu as des nuls
qui sont hyper sympa donc ça ça dépend
ça varie vraiment
alors comment on fait ici
toujours parce que j'ai l'impression que
tu prends
parce que je prends là
après un moment donné peut-être qu'il
peut y avoir une idée avec tout
reprendre
l'idée que j'avais
ce que j'ai toujours le truc en 8 qui
traîne quoi
il faudra se méfier des éléments de
8 peut-être
donc
ça a l'air bizarre le coup de Jules mais
on n'arrive pas à trouver un évidemment
les tours F7 c'est apparemment c'était
la grosse gaffe
de connards qui pourraient peut-être
permettre
il prend ici je prends la
c'est une possibilité il y a aussi les
tours 8 en plus mais le fou il faut le
bouger de façon
en fait il a l'impression du temps ça
valait le coup de se pencher sur la
position mais il a pas trouvé si bien vu
tout on va juste rapidement je suis
curieux
franchement très difficile pression du
temps d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je
vais la laisser entre guillemets parce
que il n'a peut-être pas vu lui-même
mais bien sûr c'est facile quand on met
l'ordi mais sinon on n'avait pas trouvé
hein vous voyez le joueur
c'est clair
ouais voilà donc s'il gagne là on va
sûrement
retrouver Gilles sur sur la chaîne pour
débriefer rapidement
son petit match
la jauge elle est généreuse parce que
c'est une position qui reste un peu
casse-gueule parce que le Time c'est
toujours un petit peu chaud en fait puis
on a quoi on a trois comptes 3 bon c'est
surtout le foot 15 noir aussi mais la
position noire elle est pas ridicule
mais la jauge est très très généreuse
depuis on avance alors finalement on en
a un mais en G3 c'est pas spion là
surtout la faiblesse de D5 le fou
magnifique il y a des arguments
évidemment pour les blancs pour donner
cet avantage côté de l'ordi mais on va
voir que ça va pas être si simple que ça
il va se défendre en face
en tout cas a été joué ici
il y a pas un tour prendre
[Musique]
tu peux manger prendre et prendre
un peu le bordel avec ton roi qui est un
peu bizarre donc
voilà typiquement en fait
complication pas si simple c'est la
partie en tout cas
c'est la partie
non mais en fait il va pas donner le
pionger de toute façon il va faire G4
intermézo et après croquer un an il peut
pas j'ai quatre dames aussi quand même
ok ça risque d'être la partie je le vois
bien jouer ça stable
il y a pas besoin voilà c'était sûr
attention le fond en prise là pas
voilà stable et maintenant il sait que
il a le pion de plus net
est une idée aussi
à 4 mais il y a un tout petit peu de
boulot ça commence à s'éclaircir quand
même ça se commence sentir bon attention
aussi que c'est du c'est du chaos ce qui
veut dire que les joueurs ont 4 minutes
quasiment chacun vu la bien pris son
temps il a réussi à obtenir un bel
avantage maintenant sur un rapport au
temps mais il a un peu plus de la
couleur à fond
la Tour Eiffel ça paraissait de le coup
bien stable pour faire mal
là c'est dur quand même
n'aimerait bien rentrer dans une finale
petite finale fouconde cavalier avec un
pion net de plus et le pion F3 voilà
donc tout F3 c'est pour se faciliter la
finale
et là il y a peu de coups en fait ça qui
est bien quand même avec les noirs on
est un peu coincé
ouais
c'est dur pour pour les noirs et c'est
cool pour pour Jules parce que il y a
pas de contre je crois
il y a c'est très difficile pour les
noirs de retrouver une idée trouver un
plan on n'a pas d'idées dans ce cas ça
se passe dégrader normalement
naturellement
même un coup peut-être comme menaces
à la partie
la dame et c'est d'aller manger les
pions
donc là ça répétait deux fois mais
t'inquiète pas que Jul ne veut pas faire
nul
attention
je pense
vraiment
tranquille
dans F3 donc
après on va peut-être faire des
harcèlements que attention
que ce serait peut-être une boulette
stuff
il faut pas non plus ouais
[Musique]
tu vas le faire vraiment échec prix 0 F7
c'est chaud donc là c'est vraiment pas
mal
j'ai eu peur au début excuse-moi quand
j'ai vu peur la fourchette il y a eu de
la FC 3 F7
et bah écoute ici les Blancs ont un pneu
de plus
et surtout le problème c'est HS G5
donc maintenant comment je fais je peux
juste avancer mon roi vers des quatre et
le roi est obligé de rester près de la
cage G7 pour pas se prendre le fou des
set et du coup c'est à cause de ça que
les Noirs vont perdre facilement cette
finale normalement
[Musique]
je vais pouvoir remonter mon A3 il est
C4 vraisemblablement en terme
ou B6 bloque plus l'accès à la case et
comment est-ce qu'on passe maintenant en
Z3
comment est-ce qu'on passe faites ces
câbles à un moment donné
enfin prise à cardio 5 mais
en tout cas on va essayer de zouguer
l'adversaire
pour pouvoir mettre un C4 peut-être pour
des quatre suivi de ces quatre non il a
préféré
mais bon ok ça doit être assez similaire
on peut jouer plein de petits coups
comme ça en tout cas
je sais moi j'avais déjà joué
il était
extrêmement fort
et
bon
on le connaît
maintenant j'ai le temps de jouer à Gap
il
faut s'y résoudre
je sais pas si la caméra de Collard ça
s'est arrêté je sais pas si
il est plus sur mon
il est plus sur mon sur mon truc
maintenant si la caméra non il est
revenu
c'est la connexion peut-être de colors
c'est vrai que ça te réflexion et bien
eu à 4 et maintenant on va réussir à
passer
ça va venir
voilà
et le roi va s'infiltrer
et du coup là le combat est déséquilibré
à l'aile dame ouais ça va être perdu
être sûr de faire nul
au pire
[Musique]
plusieurs choix faut C3 doit gagner
aussi mais bon avec la pression du temps
on a envie de bien calculer de pas se
faire avoir
c'est pas avoir
très bon dans ce registre
encore plus
petit coup de pion là
j'ai quatre fougères 3 bien joué et
maintenant là c'est vraiment dur il y a
plus de 15 pour le cavalier
peut-être le thème cavalier H4 en plus
il y a pas d'autre choix
petite échec
et voilà il y a deux pions ça me
rappelle la partie
juste pas se faire vous savez griller
les pions
toujours casse gueule avec 50 secondes à
la pendule peut-être fou ici c'est pas
mal ça prend les cases du du cavalier de
faire gs5 il faut des villes
ok cavalier qui tente elle est fous 3
toujours prendre le casque de cavalier
c'est important
F6 SKG cap donc
mais là il faut monter le roi là c'est
complètement gagnant mais vous voyez
comme c'est au cas où après ça peut
vraiment être
assez terrible
d'être une bonne nouvelle
le café est toujours à Tours allez
et là c'est juste terminé il fait un
échec il veut flag mais bon Jules
à peu près 18 x 1 Jules
j'y crois pas trop non j'y crois pas
trop Jules c'est pas son genre de faire
pâte dans ces positions et c'est
maintenant un coup et Jules qui qui
était en mode twin deux fois d'affilée
et qui a réussi à se qualifier
psychologue ça va sortir une énorme
partie dès la première game et
finalement je lui surpris il a pris les
blancs et puis il lui a collé aussi
super prestation
comme hier il avait été invité
sur la chaîne cheesecom
international pour pour interview et
après ça je pense on va laisser un peu
prendre ses esprits et puis on va la
voir sur la chaîne on va l'inviter il
m'avait dit
un client à cette cadence et elle lui a
bien montré les deux fois deux parties
extrêmement propres
moi il a dominé et
c'était pas facile à chaque fois était
proche d'une égalité mais jamais égal et
du coup lui a posé beaucoup de problèmes
c'est ça moi je vais mettre ma petite
studio là je vais commencer à préparer
la scène avec les joueurs qui vont
arriver
avec les Blancs qui va affronter
qui va
affronterov qui jusque là a été
franchement complètement
intraitable dans ce match avant de
Forest là j'ai pas encore sa caméra
enfin elle marche pas trop on est
plusieurs c'est pas laquelle elle est
bonne
quelle est la bonne le genre s'installe
je pense que le match va commencer dans
un instant
on voit plus serein plus serein toujours
pareil
et puis il y a bien cru en plus Collard
je pense à la faveur ça première
victoire qui était qui était propre et à
chaque fois pas si loin mais il y avait
un petit écart
ok ok bah écoute c'est cool ça fait
Jules qui se qualifie je peux vous
remontrer bien sûr le le bracket attends
c'est celui-là je vais revenir dessus
ici et vous le montrez et oui avec
carvalier
donc ça sera demain demain à partir de
17h on va avoir
on aura le droit aux deux
derniers matchs des perdants donc
carbonara contre Jules et le gagnant de
ce match carvana contre Jules contrat le
perdant perdant de
demi-finale enfin oui de la demi-finale
d'ici la fin d'heure c'est la finale
c'est c'est
final du premier tableau à envoyer le
premier tableau au plan de Forest hams
ils arrivent au bout du tableau ça ça
c'est une petite finale et le perdant de
la petite finale ce qu'elle est ici pour
une
une autre calife à la grande finale
enfin je sais pas si vous comprenez
voyez là vous avez le looser final et en
fait donc là le gagnant de ce blues d'or
semi-finale et ben aura sa place dans le
loser final contre le perdant du
de la finale d'en haut et l'autre
gagnant sera grande finale qui est au
bout et le gagnant après de de la looser
final affrontera le grand gagnant de
tout le tournoi et il faudra le battre
deux fois on avait eu le cas on avait eu
le cas c'était lors de la dernière
édition avec carvana qui avait tout
gagné jusqu'au bout
et qui a éliminé Nakamura et elle
Nakamura il a tout gagné en dessous et
il est remonté jusqu'à arriver en finale
et vous savez que pour être éliminé de
la compétition il faut il faut il faut
perdre deux matchs donc Nakamura qui
avait déjà perdu un match contre Kawana
et ben devait le battre deux fois car on
a il avait 0 défaite donc c'est normal
que si Nakamura
batawana et ben il faut probable
derrière une défaite chacun donc ça tu
vois et donc il a battu deux matchs
d'affilée et
et Naka s'est proclamé champion du Grand
festo de la dernière édition et
maintenant madame kamura a perdu au
premier tour enfin il a perdu
et contre qui vient de perdre contre
large ouais dommage pour aller résa qui
à la faveur c'est deux grosses gaffes du
jour ben sort du tournoi alors qu'il
avait montré franchement aujourd'hui
contre caroanna que il est bien présent
alors certes il a fait deux grosses
gaffes mais dans la première il avait
vraiment archi dominé dans la deuxième
c'était encore très intéressant le
résultat aurait pu vraiment être inversé
après c'est les échecs mais il doit être
vraiment déçu de la manière quoi de la
manière parce qu'il avait les cartes en
main et il a fait des bêtises rares
quand même à ce niveau là vu qu'il est
ru est resté en tout cas dans la
deuxième partie du temps
bon en tout cas on va revenir un petit
peu notre bracket et donc là on va
passer maintenant les joueurs qui n'ont
pas encore perdu de match donc on a 20
forest contre
on n'a pas encore la partie qui est
lancée on sait pas qui est blanc qui est
noir là il y a quatre parties dans match
donc pour le premier carême 2 et demi
gagne et en cas d'égalité et ben on va
procéder au
départage en Armageddon comme on vient
de le voir avec Jules d'ailleurs je vais
vous changer le titre parce que là le
quart de finale déperdans ce n'est plus
le bon titre
[Musique]
et ciel bleu il nous dit connard ça fait
un super tournoi c'est la grosse
surprise de le voir si loin il ne doit
pas être déçu mais sur le moment
nul lui suffisait sur les deux parties
au final bah il a pas réussi à faire son
demi sur deux après avoir gagné
brillamment même si Jules est plus fort
sur le papier bah c'est un super joueur
aussi Collard c'est
il savait qu'il avait ses chances à
cette case là donc c'est ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est de voir qu'en
fait je pense que les deux joueurs
étaient très content de se jouer tu vois
franchement un tournoi comme celui-ci
ils sont arrivés assez dur normalement
ce que je veux dire c'est que Jules je
pense c'est bien content de le contre
collarse pendant que crawlars lui aussi
est bien content je compte Jul parce que
bah ils auraient pu tous les deux avoir
un virus là un carwana etc
voilà plutôt sur le papier mais après
bah maintenant ça te permet de faire
plus de chance de gagner aussi et donc
là c'est un match qui est très très
compliqué et c'est Jules qui l'a emporté
donc on est on est hyper content je vais
je vais je vais appeler Jules attendez
je vais je vais l'appeler donc du coup
tu sais ce qu'il faut faire
et on va la voir d'ici quelques instants
là
je vais vous mettre la caméra comme
d'habitude dès qu'il sera là je me je me
cacherai derrière j'ai eu
on va attendre quand même que je
l'arrive
et il est là hop là
hop
salut Jules ça va ouais ça va bravo à
toi salut alors attends
Jules qui vient de se qualifier pour
pour la finale des perdants
ça paraît pas bien comme ça mais en vrai
ça de la gueule c'est pas la finale
encore c'est la demi-finale exactement
parce que le gagnant va jouer contre le
perdant de Van forest à torov on a le on
a le bracket ici donc je pense que vous
le voyez là ça y est à la caméra tu as
pris ma place je trouve tu as pas oublié
un micro quelque part non j'ai peut-être
oublié un micro alors tu m'as dit de le
faire mais tu l'as pas fait je me suis
bien pris de ta gueule avant de le faire
et j'oublie de le faire moi-même c'est
typique et tout ça t'inquiète
alors Jules tu as l'impression ce match
oh là là c'est trop c'est match non
c'est trop vraiment
c'est pas possible
c'était très très close
avec les Noirs c'était difficile la
première
mais en fait je me suis plus rappelé de
foudre parce que je sais qu'il y a du
fouet 4 dans cette ligne de partout
mais c'est pas là et après il a fait une
super partie j'ai l'impression
regardez vite fait je regarde un peu
avec l'ordi après moi c'est un ordi un
peu faible mais
les deux autres ça avait l'air quand
même assez propre que tu as fait Jules
non
je sais pas alors là franchement je
pense que la deuxième c'est pas propre
du tout et la troisième non plus en fait
non parce qu'en fait la deuxième ce qui
se passe c'est que il a des déconnexions
et en fait moi je le regardais et du
coup ça m'a complètement déconcentré
aussi je pense qu'on est tous les deux
sorties de la partie parce que je le
voyais d'un côté j'avais pas envie de
gagner comme ça mais de l'autre je le
voyais qu'il se reconnectait donc je me
suis dit en fait je réfléchis je parle
du temps pour rien donc ça au final ça
l'arrange et j'ai réfléchi un moment une
bonne minute dans le vide
mais bon je pense que ça a pas trop
changé mais j'ai mal joué je pense à un
moment en fait le problème parce que
c'est drôle c'est que
je voulais absolument éviter cette ligne
et je suis tombé dedans par hasard c'est
quand même génial en fait je voulais
jouer ce que j'ai joué dans l'Armageddon
ouais ok
[Musique]
et je me rappelais absolument rien et
c'est super chaud après c'était pas
mécontent d'avoir un truc chaud
mais il connaissait je crois que ouais
je crois que ça c'est pas très bien
passé par contre l'Armageddon je sais
que tu auras 8 normalement c'est pas le
coup mais alors est-ce que je peux le
punir j'avais peur de
en fait pour un 8 est-ce que ouais là
c'est quoi le coup c'est cavalier B3
alors on a nous on a on regarde toujours
sans ordinateur donc pour te dire la
vérité à prendre la théorie clairement
si tu veux alors l'ordinateur il donne à
quatre cavaliers
mais faudrait que je vois sur un bon
ordi
j'ai joué j'ai joué normal mais en fait
il y a pas grand chose dans cette ligne
c'est juste pour jouer je me suis dit
j'ai envie de jouer un truc pas trop
théorique pas trop fort ça on garde des
pièces pour toujours avoir le backup
pour le flab au cas où
c'était d'ailleurs faut penser ça parce
que tu as joué d'ailleurs c'était
super dur là on a regardé avec l'ordi
justement parce que bien sûr on avait
une indication en fait j'ai vu et j'ai
vu pourquoi et après je suis allé voir
effectivement
ça marche pas c'était hyper dur à
trouver
en fait j'ai eu l'idée donc j'ai fini
par le voir mais en fait ce que j'ai
raté au début c'est que je pensais que
fou français 7 j'ai vu cette idée de ton
premier T3 mais dans le mauvais ordre
donc j'ai pensé
Tour Eiffel
et en fait là je suis content parce que
je prends le 4 tours D8 MP3 il peut pas
prendre froid parce qu'il est super et
on restait après en fait comment tu
réfléchissais que je me suis dit mais en
fait il peut il peut jouer à un G7
on voit c'est pas facile dans l'autre
ordre
et là du coup bah je sais pas ce que
j'aurais fait ben tu es pas bien en fait
après mais
prends G5 il y a peut-être le coup
opportuniste une fois que tu es un peu
dans la merde avec cette histoire
du délire total
une fois que tu es là il faut il faut
assumer quoi
[Musique]
je reprends
c'est pas le stockage sur ton pc c'est
par défaut de toute façon il aurait
fallu faire quelque chose quoi
malheureusement c'est
ouais en tout cas et ton et ton choix de
prendre les blancs alors tu viens déjà
c'est pas un choix en fait on bide c'est
à dire que tu donnes le temps que tu
veux c'est celui qui
a donné le
le plus bas choisit la couleur ouais
mais du coup comme je l'ai vu tu as mis
10-47 je me suis dit que tu voulais
absolument pas les Noirs non en fait je
me suis dit que il allait comprendre
qu'en fait vu qu'il fait que gagner et
perdre il allait bide plus pour avoir
justement les blancs
le premier match il a gagné trois
parties perdu 2 le deuxième il a perdu
deux parties
il en a gagné une et une nulle qui
aurait pu être aller dans les deux sens
donc je me suis dit si j'ai les blancs
franchement vu la dynamique de ce mec
toutes mes chances de gagner ou perdre
mais bon peu importe alors que la nul
bon il a l'air de
[Musique]
noir
je me suis dit si j'ai 10 47 avec les
Noirs je suis content mais en dessous
comme je suis assez long en plus là en
ce moment je me suis dit que c'était pas
une bonne idée donc j'étais content de
nous 10-47 je me suis dit non c'est
clair c'est bien parce que c'était les
Noirs bon bah ça a marché
[Musique]
j'ai pas été précis
é
une petite crise cardiaque quand même un
moment ouais parce que je joue fous des
4 et je pensais que c'était trois fois
plus et en fait j'ai vu qu'il avait une
de connexion mais je me suis dit oh le
il me semblent
trois fois je vais péter un plomb
et non en fait et là je te jure je
regardais plus je me suis dit ça fait
trois fois
ça faisait nuit la croix F7 ça ça a
beaucoup tourné en fait ça devait être
après là voilà je pense hein
par là
et ça franchement ça fait deux fois mais
c'était trois fois c'était la même ouais
mais là le roi est en G6
ça faisait trois fois mais en fait
oui le mec cavalier je pense que tu sais
pourquoi
ça parce que je crois que
[Musique]
d'habitude c'est moi de jouer à lui de
jouer et là c'est à moi parce que quand
d'habitude il faisait cavalier à 5 et je
faisais roisser deux
serment c'est peut-être pas le bon truc
bien en tout cas bon tu es moche Queen
pour pas jouer avec ça quoi non mais je
sais mais en fait le j'ai jamais joué un
tournoi comme ça et j'ai une pression de
dingue d'ailleurs déjà les prix sont des
trucs que j'ai jamais vu dans dans mes
tournois
et puis en plus je sais pas tu es l'art
magazine tout le monde qui te regarde tu
fais une connerie tout à l'heure
sûrement débile donc je me suis dit
peut-être une pression et je réfléchis
pas comme d'habitude je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que je suis plus lent et
puis même je me questionne trop je suis
trop lent quoi alors quand tu veux la
maison en caleçon en fait toujours
l'impression que tu joues beaucoup mieux
que que je te prenouve tout et je gagne
facile
donc c'est quand même globalement tu as
fait le taf franchement
mais il va falloir que je me prépare
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
tout le temps et puis à la fin c'est un
peu chaud enfin disons que
la
technique elle est un petit peu un peu
chaude quoi au final parce que c'est pas
si simple d'avoir un peu à poil et
enfin en deux à la fin et la partie et
l'autre partie il a deux tours il a une
tour et deux fous pour la dame et de
pions et il a filé le four quoi mais en
un coup ou pas
de passer n'importe quoi et Messi roi a
donné la partie deux fois donc
la surprise après moi je veux pas
réfléchir trop loin mais
je risque de jouer Jordan quand même
parce que quand même assez dangereux
les prix tu déconnais ou pas j'imagine
que les prix
faut pas que j'en parle parce que ça va
me ça me stresse bon on parle on en
parlera peut-être que je serai parti
alors parce que moi j'ai des brackets
ici là je peux je peux vous démontrer
compris les prix sont gros mais en fait
tu rajoutes un certain truc parce que
c'est un c'est un champion de chez toi
donc tu as des prix qui se rajoute parce
que tu as des points de Tours tu es
aussi qualifié pour un autre truc donc
en fait le prix le premier prix est
doublé en fait ça peut être exponentiel
je pense que je prends plus que ce qui
est écrit avec les points que je gratte
je dirais je sais pas on va voir bon en
tout cas en tout cas je pense que les
calculs c'est pas forcément bon pour toi
maintenant mais trop la pression il faut
que je vais mettre par match voir demain
ce qui se passe contre Kawana et puis
bah écoute carvana je pense que un bon
petit match et et tu peux le faire la
gorge hein
j'ai beaucoup moins de pression
je ressens pas du tout la pression comme
ça sur l'échiquier c'est internet ça me
c'est pas toujours mauvais d'avoir la
pression mais là des fois des fois c'est
un peu trop je sais pas pourquoi
[Musique]
je pense premièrement comme ça
il en a fait il en a combien
oui oui toujours premier connecté sur le
zoom je le vois à chaque fois là 45
minutes avant et c'est une idée
en tout cas merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Jules d'être passé et puis
gros gros
merde pour demain et demain je pense
même si je perds
pas mais en tout cas c'est cool tu
m'écris pour demain il y a pas de souci
on te voit plus on est content donc
c'était beau aujourd'hui plus qu'à faire
pareil demain ça marche yes allez bravo
repose-toi bien
à bientôt ciao ciao à bientôt
voilà Jules qui vient de partir on va
repartir sur sur discord ça te va bien
sûr bien sûr
mais voilà moi je suis de retour sur Obs
et donc Jules qui vient de nous quitter
on est très content bien sûr d'avoir pu
voir encore la chance de revoir Jules
sur le stream c'est vrai qu'on a de la
chance de pouvoir
c'est cool hein il faut le tournoi là il
est en demi-finale des perdant bien et
puis il est hyper sympa donc tu as vu
c'est marrant elle n'était pas très
satisfait quand je regarde la qualité
des parties honnêtement bon après il est
à chaud mais
on peut faire la précision juste c'est
parti vite fait
la fameuse précision de chasse comme
il faudrait que je passe
85 la première qu'il gagne donc la
numéro 2 93 pardon avec les Blancs à 93
la troisième il fait 93.2
et la première qui perd
il fait 4 heures non il avait noir il
fait 77
c'est très fort c'est très fort c'est 93
quoi ah oui
clairement pas et bon ok mais en fait
quand tu as chaud tu as des regrets
parce que tu peux analyser la partie
mais on en aison il va reprendre en fait
bon totalement ok parce qu'il a fait et
puis en fait il parlait de stress que
lui il stresse etc parce que la première
fois qu'ils ont un événement
comme ça je pense que le niveau du
stress et en plus que là il avait des
problèmes de connexion donc en fait ils
devaient tilter enfin voilà
mais en tout cas en tout cas hyper
content que demain il joue de famille
c'est ce qu'il voulait un candidat je
veux contre
Abdou il a perdu le match était vraiment
difficile en face c'était vraiment un
robot vraiment il était hyper fort et à
la fin il me dit que enfin avec avec
Laurent il nous a dit que il espère
pouvoir battre shimanov pour derrière
pour voir rejoindre un groupe
bon après il est pas non plus mécontent
de jouer un jour son niveau pour pouvoir
essayer de gagner et passer des étapes
mais un peu comme tout le monde il a ses
yeux d'enfants c'est les mecs Fabiana
carbonara c'est un mec qui est top
niveau top 5 et même top 3 depuis perds
longtemps enfin tu vois il a été très
très longtemps le le challenger
annonçait de Magnus du coup bah lui il
kiffe ça aussi il parlait des prix mais
il y a aussi c'était appréhension de de
jouer des joueurs de d'une telle force
des noms en fait des non bah oui c'est
clair
c'est clair et ouais que même à ce
niveau là même Jules qui est champion de
France qui est pas loin 2700 hello en
particulier mais même lui et ben il rêve
de rue contre ces joueurs là enfin vous
voyez un peu les différentes un peu de
classe tu vois c'est c'est pour ça qu'on
joue je pense que tout le monde on adore
bah justement nous on veut jouer contre
des joueurs comme Jules quand on fait
des grosses compétitions et bah j'ai lui
qui a un autre niveau bah veut jouer les
meilleurs du monde
c'est
hyper intéressant nous on a banalisé
aussi cela pour être de plus en plus
près mentalement quand il va jouer ces
joueurs là donc c'est à tout niveau
c'est bénéfique techniquement et
psychologiquement quand on a joué en
National de la montée contre contre Agen
ils avaient pris ils avaient pas de
Mario
bien sûr pour nos Mario en fait c'est le
rêve tout le monde de le jouer qui a été
champion du monde bon
on était plusieurs à pouvoir monter au
premier chéquier enfin moi je suis pas
dedans moi je peux pas monter comme un
chèque mais on avait plusieurs joueurs
qui plus le premier chéquier et pour
nous c'était sûr c'était normalement
Guillaume qui jouait au premier
architecte tout le temps et
il voulait il voulait jouer pendant le
mariage mais en fait en termes stratégie
d'équipe
c'était pas forcément une bonne idée de
le mettre lui au loin et en fait bon on
inscrite tous ensemble
pendant qu'on mangeait quoi et au final
on va pas mieux voir mais lui
il était trop content de pouvoir je
comprends pas
etc et dans un match normal on s'en
foutait
un jour comme ça
toujours cool moi j'avais moi j'ai
jamais vraiment joué de grosse légende
en partie lente bon quand même je vous
révis
j'ai joué
j'ai joué à courroie box
c'est bon déjà
joué à Laurent
très expérimenté d'anciennes légendes
mais j'ai pas joué de joueurs enfin de
2007 tu vois enfin je parle partie vente
parce que sur internet
en rapide parce qu'il habite pas loin de
là où j'habitais en France dès qu'il y
avait un rapide bah
il venait et du coup j'ai plein de fois
mais ça fait toujours plaisir en fait
bien sûr
le top ou les open très forts qu'il y
avait encore moi j'ai joué Étienne en
Corse par exemple
et du coup c'est c'est c'est vraiment
génial et sinon de se faire le plaisir
le kiff de d'aller au chemin d'Europe
adulte aussi qu'il y avait eu en 2011
j'avais joué jobava Vito golf à suivre
c'était quand même c'était quand même
pas mal quoi
au théâtre Bastien ok
j'ai joué là-bas
peut-être ma dernière fois j'avais fait
un super tournoi rapide bien sûr je vois
bien et
il y avait 9 rondes et les je crois que
les 14 premiers du tournoi se qualifiés
pour les Beatles de finale il y avait
deux invités c'était amande et où une
femme je crois OK et
donc bon non c'est pas ouf
ou en wifi comme ça
et puis les grands qualifient
généralement c'est un mec qui qui
poussent un peu quoi tu vois c'est bien
sûr très fort et j'avais fait un super
tournoi j'ai battu peut-être j'avais
battu Adrien de but
j'avais battu un autre grand maître à 25
et puis après j'ai fait yoyo
2006 quoi et donc en termes de de
performance et de départage était pas si
mal et en plus la dernière ronde
dernièrement du tournoi et ben j'ai
entre guillemets beaucoup de chance
parce que je suis sur 8 et je joue avec
les Noirs donc je double les Noirs
contre lui jouer un maître international
qui a 2400 hello OK et avec 6 sur 8 et
lui aussi il est content moi j'avais
même pas 2003 à l'époque j'ai un peu
moins bien sûr et
en fait cette pensée
qualifié à cette point et si c'est demi
bon ça dépend des partages mon projet
quoi et tu vois que à côté de moi il y
avait peut-être romain Édouard qui
jouait c'est pas un goussain love enfin
tu vois le niveau monstrueux et moi
contre lui donc se jouer
et dernière ronde voilà je veux contre
lui et j'ai une position avec trois non
plus complètement gagnant et ce qui est
fou en fait
c'est que je te promets c'est véridique
mais peut-être deux jours avant de
voyager
j'ai rêvé
que non mais
dans mon sommeil j'ai rêvé que
j'affrontais un ande sur l'estrade sur
la scène tu sais j'ai rêvé et pendant
pas tant que ça dans la partie pendant
la partie j'ai mais en fait bon oui mais
j'ai pas de la présentation mais c'est
pas se passer et en fait si je gagne la
partie bon déjà il y avait un bon petit
chèque qui m'attendait
pas au niveau des prix
c'était du je crois que c'était 750 ou
un truc comme ça bon mais au-delà de
l'argent que je le sais que je le prends
bien sûr mais au-delà de l'argent tu
jouais contre
[Musique]
j'étais encore élo donc je compte un
nombre c'était plus fort que plus faible
et j'aurais joué un an de en
aller-retour sur la scène
et finalement ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai perdu la partie je me suis pris un
truc débile ce n'est que c'était une
structure un petit peu genre catalane et
donc finketo et le pion HD il est parti
on leur argent même structure champion 3
et je voulais placer une tactique ou en
fait à la fin il y avait un temple G3
échec parce que j'avais un fou sur la
diagonale qui cloué le pion F et elle
prend est interdit parce qu'il y avait
plus on était cloué et sur dame prend
live a fait genre le fou G2 j'ai mis un
Cavalaire pour m'attend à l'âge de bref
et au final à un moment donné
et Madame devient emprise et à ce moment
là j'ai un matin
et après ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
regardé mon adversaire
jouer à Nantes
la plus grosse je pense la plus grosse
déception
je m'en souviens encore c'était hier
dans les histoires du Corsican bon
pareil joyeux soupape on me qualifier
déjà c'est pas mal en terme de légende
tu vois et en fait j'ai les noirs et je
fais vraiment une pure partie et
vraiment je lui fais du mal j'ai une
pièce de plus
j'ai deux minutes contre 30 secondes
donc bon autant dire je vais gagner et
puis là bah je joue le coup qui va le
forcer à abandonner dame prend tour et
s'il prend ma dame mat du couloir sauf
qu'il m'a pris madame mais en fait ça
contrôlait la case de maths de couloir
tu vois ce que font on se rejoint dans
les bases anecdotes mais ce qui est
assez réconfortant dans ce cas-là c'est
quand ta conjointe te dit à ce moment-là
même moi j'avais vu
voilà ça c'est le réconfort juste que tu
sais quand tu as perdu tu vois elle dit
punaise même moi j'avais vu et ça
c'était beau quand même ça reste assez
gravé tu vois j'étais content en plus
bah non en fait non pas du tout et puis
en plus de réconfort de la petite phrase
qui tue
bien que des enfants donc vous avez
tellement tiqué que enfin il faut garder
un peu la face quoi au niveau de
l'accepter la défaite et bon là c'était
c'était juste horrible
l'effort que j'ai fait pour pas être en
titre dans mes enfants je te raconte
même pas bien sûr
ça donne envie de pleurer comme on dit
trop mais c'est le même effet quoi
et finalement bah les parents d'autre
à la prochaine fois
la réalité la config non mais c'est
impossible
à ça bien sûr
c'est toujours pareil
je me serais fait défoncer mais on s'en
fout tu vois c'est le casting tu vois
non téléphone
d'ailleurs tu parlais d'Adrien de Mute
qui est quand même bon c'est un fort
grand maître Adrien presque 25 50 mais
bon là un peu moins en ce moment 25 je
pense mais il a battu un an dans partie
j'ai vu la partie Adrien qui l'a battu
en
ça veut dire que si Adrien il a battu un
monde et toi tu as battuce
ça serait normal c'est le classique donc
en fait on peut dire que Amanda est à ça
de contre moi en fait d'accord ok bah
c'est plus sympa de le voir comme ça en
fait
et sauf pour revenir la partie qu'on a
pas trop commenté parce que il y a eu de
Jules et après nos belles anecdotes mais
on va pas perdre la vague les blancs on
roi des trois rois c'est deux rois B2
j'ai peur de me prendre
bon on peut aller gratter des pions nous
aussi avec le roi mais ça paraît on
paraît beaucoup plus avancé quoi donc
van forest il doit se poser des
questions ça a joué vite
mais il doit pas être serein il vient de
jouer au 4 c'est joli c'est un bravo à
lui excellent coup et peut-être le seul
coup d'ailleurs je trouve pour revenir
soit se créer un pion passé si je joue
au roi des trois square revenir juste à
temps pour empêcher le roi de partir en
Détroit c'est ça ça me rappelle là ça me
rappelle une partie qu'on avait vu de
entre
quinzaine et ventes forest cette finale
où il y avait une course de pions des
deux côtés ça a fait nul assez facile
pour une forest mais ça me fait penser à
un truc comme ça en tout cas en fin de
phrase qui calcule très très bien et il
est pas loin de perdre parce que si le
roi part en Détroit ça peut très vite
perdre mais attention que c'est droit
avant le temps maintenant passe un pion
passé puis moi aussi je peux venir
accompagner que mon roi quoi donc
là une vitesse folle surtout parce que
il a 6 minutes 13 à 1200 c'est pas le
joueur le plus long du circuit
bah c'est beaucoup et puis la position
paraissait difficile visuellement je
dirais c'est bizarre
les valves parce que je n'avais pas vu
E4 évidemment sauf et franchement quelle
classe et ça y est maintenant on peut
dire enfin je joue là pour le coup il y
a de très très fortes chances de nulle
que si le roi ne passe pas et ben
évidemment le pion a émulé
ouais ouais bien sûr on voit que c'est
pour ça que je posais la question roi
des trois roisés de roi B2 et en fait E4
c'est marrant parce que ça contrôle pas
la case des trois mais si roi des trois
eux prend des 5 et on a un pion passé
nous aussi très avancé c'est vraiment le
chantage quoi vas-y
maintenant il faut même faire gaffe on a
peur de le faire bah ouais donc il va
prendre le cadre on va prendre un cadre
ils vont jouer quelques coups et je
pense nul
possible
parce que si je fais échecs toujours pas
faire faire les trois j'en ai pu rentrer
faire défendre le pion et je reviens
quoi tu vois c'est possible que cette
répétition après je sais que que Abdou
il joue vraiment enfin c'est un joueur
qui qui est très très fight
tour à 5 et F5
il veut gagner toutes les parties
en tout cas c'est clair que là il est
pas moins bien avec les noirs
de manière un peu lente
et ça paraît dur de
est-ce qu'un peut être une idée avec
Android
pour se créer un rappel et tant que le
roi par là-bas maintenant je prends mais
la joueur roi c'est deux pour conserver
la config bien sûr il veut garder le
pion le pion g pour empêcher H4
et on peut même après passer la tour de
l'autre côté pour mettre le roux en
sécurité par rapport au pion a TF3 j'ai
pensé pour jouer des tours
et là à trois alors attends il met la
pression on a pas vraiment il y a tout
rache un tour H4 non
j'essaie de faire comme Van forest
maintenant on calcule et on bloque je
sais pas
j'essaie de faire pareil mais c'est
peut-être la version discount
parce que j'arrive
comment ça alors je sais pas on va la
revoir rapidement
et je vais t'envoyer mon pion G
tu peux dominer pendant très longtemps
elle se retrouve en Forest et je trouve
que alors du coup
comme si c'était hyper facile comme ça
peut-être ou pas avant ma souris je
voulais venir en H4
et faire quoi
ouais
mais ça a pas l'air de marcher hein
je contrôle le pion
bien sûr qu'il y a dans la reine
[Musique]
c'est pas mal vu d'ailleurs il pose les
problèmes quand même avec ce F3 alors il
risque d'avoir plein de changements je
pense vraiment qu'ils vont faire nul
mais
c'est exactement ce que tu avais dit il
pose les problèmes mais là je pense que
tu peux plus gagner en fait
un peu partout oui mais en fait
partie une nuit un petit peu en
souffrance quand même pour vendre forest
avec les Blancs on a vu tout à l'heure
il a une position difficile par contre
il a réussi à la défendre
en calcul
en fait il est très concret
déjà
qui m'étonne c'est la vitesse aussi
parce que bon c'est toujours pareil
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui m'est pas de
chez eux ok trouver les variantes mais
avec le temps imparti souvent ils sont
ils sont fous à ce niveau-là
en train de
c'est en train de se liquider d'où cette
mort
ça va faire nuit je vois pas trop trop
de de
ou un joueur ne gagne pas
supporter de ventes
ok parce que si tu prends ben j'ai la
même position qu'avant sauf que dans
celle-là quand tu manges ici bah j'ai
mon roi là il t'a pas la pointe d'appui
F4
un peu énervant voilà
400 laisser passer le roi juste en lui
laissant H5
vraiment le coup du professionnel
bien sûr faut pas que je fasse F2 et H4
donc ok bon il y a encore quelques
petites choses mais
bien sûr
ça va faire
et puis mais bon
c'est pas le coup de l'année faut le
montrer
ça c'est le coup
du bistro voilà attention coup du joueur
4 buts
[Musique]
ça risque de répéter parce que
tu parles trop loin avec ton roi bien
sûr
il y a pas de
il y a pas de de cas où il fait un truc
un si le roi va trop loin par exemple
voyez et ben il peut y avoir qui arrive
bon rappelle c'est presque 2007 ça a été
2007 et en plus il a déjà gagné le tata
style qui a une compétition majeure du
circuit
du top mondial donc c'est pas rigolo on
le voit dans cette partie car nous ça
t'auras c'est très fort et il a réussi
quand même dans une situation difficile
à trouver tous les coups trouve tous les
mecs
très très fort et ça fait nul par
répétition
depuis tout à l'heure et donc ça c'est
la première partie de
de
ce minimax donc cette petite finale des
gagnants
donc
belle finale en tout cas
est-ce que le via c'est la mémoire ou la
logique qui fait la différence
la mémoire le calcul aussi parce que
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose de
se souvenir et de calculer comme du
calcul mental on va dire et
la logique mais en fait c'est le tout en
fait c'est comme voilà tu cite des
compétences et cette somme de compétence
finalement il y a l'Hexagone de
compétence il faut qu'il soit le plus
haut donc possible ça dépend des joueurs
en plus il y en a qui qui sont plus
forts sur certains aspects du jeu que
d'autres mais c'est vraiment des micros
micro différents ils sont quasiment
parfaits les joueurs là sur quasiment
tout mais il y a des petites différences
quand même
c'est quoi un bon PC pour utiliser stock
fish un exemple le mieux c'est un PC
fixe mais tu ça marche aussi avec de
très bons ordinateurs portables
mais il faut il faut des bons
processeurs sauf
ça va très bien
comme bien sûr starfish fonctionnera
mais plus vite il a sur des profondeurs
hautes bah plus il sera performant j'ai
en entrée longtemps travaillé avec des
PC portables ça me convenait bien en
tournoi de toute façon j'ai pas le choix
mais c'est vrai que depuis que j'ai un
PC fixe je vois que ça mouline plus vite
voilà plus vite c'est plus concret c'est
vrai que après normalement vous avez pas
besoin parce que Jules en parlait tout à
l'heure mais il veut une très bonne Eva
etc parce que en théorie il doit être
parfait parce qu'il joue des mecs qui
sont se préparent parfaitement et qui
sont extrêmement forts normalement vous
n'avez pas non plus besoin de bête de
concours absolument pour connaître la
dernière nouveauté au 15e coup la
validait avec le PC etc
ce qui est plus le cas des joueurs qu'on
voit là
yes est-ce qu'on partirait pas en pause
c'est l'heure de la pause
5 minutes on va avoir la revanche et
puis ben rester connecté en tout cas par
ceux qui pour ceux qui sont là et on
revient d'ici un court instant à tout de
suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour alors est-ce que
ça reprit
kevinienne avec vous deux à l'instant on
voit qu'on a réactif au niveau des
droits à un beau tour de force dans la
finale de Jordan van forest qui était en
difficulté estanienne C5 un peu moins
réputé que la traditionnelle espagnole
avec E5
ouverture donc bien sûr
il y a des problèmes sur le pion des 6
aussi mais bon comme il y a eu cavalier
des deux qui bloque la dame D1
simplement grave le cavalier peut passer
aussi dans ses schémas par a6 C7 ou A6
B4 si la cata
mais ça paraît effectivement quand tu
vois ça
tu dis que c'est assez cool après j'ai
joué 50 Christian boire avec les Blancs
qui aiment les ouvertures atypiques on
va avoir réussi à s'en sortir avec avec
ce genre ce genre d'idées
ça reste tu sais on a beau avoir un
centre
avoir l'espace au centre avancé des
belles pièces ça peut se retourner avec
ce fou G7 qui est ouvert pour toute la
partie et qui est braqué sur l'eldame de
loin là avec ce rayon laser sur le pion
B2 souvent ça peut ça peut mal tourner
maintenant j'ai envie de jouer petit
rock le coup cavalier des deux aussi
était vraiment très bien pensé parce que
ça évite tu sais les schémas pion prend
des 5 puis on prend des cinq cavaliers 4
pour échanger les pièces et faire vivre
le Fougeret c'est vraiment une des idées
fondamentales de la position
cavaliers E4 voilà et on est on est ça y
est à l'égalité presque en tout cas
c'est des bonnes nouvelles c'est des
échanges là avec la valorisation du Fou
G7 les pièces qui sont de plus en plus
belles
du coup c'est plutôt bien
donc prise en dessin
il y a deux écoles
sur ces branches je pense qu'on va avoir
droit à un B5 probablement oui
[Musique]
de Benny ça que je dois dire évidemment
avec la majorité elle dames contre le
centre là tu nous fais une petite folie
en B5 mais c'est le classique avec la
récupération du pion central
à la fois et au moulin
c'est pour cette raison que eux prend
des 5 pareil des fois beaucoup plus
logique donc
c'est position là aussi il existe
parfois des sacrifices en 3 avec fois H6
un jeu sur case noir là c'est peut-être
un peu exagéré mais en tout cas cette
idée là il faudra y faire tout de suite
attention parce que c'est pas c'est pas
n'importe quoi j'ai déjà vu ça dans des
parties et d'ailleurs on voit que la
jaugeique pas trop tu vois pour ce type
de sa crise de qualité et
c'est assez normal en fait
on a on aurait un fou surpuissant sur
case noire sur le long terme
ok donc le premier 5 on va voir un peu
comment toujours en tout cas
généralement il est quand même assez
assez bien préparé dans les ouvertures
et ils jouent très très vite et c'est
vrai qu'en cette partie là ben écoute on
avait dit coup il a déjà dépensé
surprenant c'est surprenant mais donc
bonne soirée ce qui
je pense et peut-être content de sa
prépa
comme quoi on peut jouer beaucoup de
choses aux échec même dans les échecs
modernes
voit que la jauge disait que c'était
bien et finalement c'est pas si c'est
clair voilà il a poussé son B5
donc il va réussir à avoir cette
position avec celle qu'on a dit donc B5
qui live
ça m'avait l'air moins stable si tu veux
souffre je me disais que les Noirs a
fait vraiment une bonne opération dans
l'ouverture
moi j'aime bien la personne moi qui est
qui je voulais indienne qui est le plan
très longtemps
et Benco et ben écoute là je suis ravi
avec les noirs
ah oui il appelle qui qui va qui va il
va s'arrêter
avec que vu le fait d'avoir
je viens de comprendre ok on a changé de
statut
ok ok
voilà c'était la suite logique le thème
clé
maintenant comment on joue cette
position
la SC4 pour mettre le cavalier sur son
poste typique dans ces structures Benoni
Benko c'est tellement thématique que ça
a l'air ça a l'air très très bien c'est
ce qui va jouer je pense mais le
cavalier B5 n'est pas très bien placé il
y aura 6 cavaliers à 3 ça va être ça la
suite de la partie
à moi qui me surprenne mais c'est
tellement logique que
6 cavaliers à 300 savait pourquoi parce
que le cavalier de venir en C4 pour ne
pas s'échanger pour presser et sur assis
on fait cavalier à 3 c'est sûr qu'il
avait vu jusque là les deux joueurs
d'ailleurs
ok ça doit être un petit plus quand même
pour les blancs parce que le KFC 4 est
vraiment très bien placé super case
D6 toute la partie aura un problème puis
aussi il y a aussi la casse qui pourrait
être un jour être peut-être contrôlé par
ce cavalier donc faudra juste que je
m'organise pour libérer ma tour et
peut-être faire un B3 à un moment
qui arrive
donc
on va plutôt voir je pense prise et ce
qui prendra jusqu'au bout ça a l'air
logique
mais
c'est ce qu'il a vu en tout fait
évidemment
tourbéen qu'est-ce que je fais bah je
viens
j'aime bien tout Rasset ici parce que
sinon tu vas m'embêter souffle et du
coup
tu auras ça c'est très souple
ça ne règle pas tout à fait le problème
de d'un jour jouer qu'à valider cette
belle conception ouais
d'avoir ce cavalier un monstrueux en C4
il va en fait paralyser complètement le
cavalier à B8 parce que tant que le
cavalier enfin attendre
on ne pourra jamais sortir ce cavalier à
moins de jours au préalable comme si
c'est tout à fait mais dans les deux cas
c'est compliqué par exemple
que je pensais qui avait l'air
tu peux prendre et jouer des 6 enfin la
totale quoi
c'est une horreur absolue et c'est
marrant parce que des fois les
joueurs d'élite comme ça ils planchent
sur des positions on aurait peut-être
rapidement jouer cavalier A3 enfin en
tout cas c'est mon cas
sauf et cavalier C3 une fois qu'on l'a
sous les yeux bah on comprend mais à
cette cadence là bah j'ai pas scotché
non plus 100000 ans sur cavalier A3 mais
qui a laissé trois c'est super
intéressant
et franchement ailleurs
un petit peu
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est un prix qui a l'air
extrêmement bien joué par les Blancs
manger ou pas d'ailleurs
trouver un coup mais il cherche quand
même
parce que fou ces trois tourbéens il
doit être embêté alors peut-être qu'il
jouera tout à 7 ou quelque chose d'autre
mais c'est pas c'est pas si facile
c'était pour justement être un peu
profilactique par rapport à tous les
menaces mais tu en auras encore un
souffle
et le football
aussi
ça a l'air
en pratique c'est
[Musique]
c'est
simplement
en pratique c'est juste
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est écrasant
il défend ici parce que ils prennent à
ce niveau il travaille la position était
difficile en pratique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre il est
perdu enfin j'ai pas m'amuser à le
défendre c'est pas le but
ça empêche que
du coup c'est trop trop dur je trouve
dans ma carte c'est un excellent cours
souffle
il faut regarder les trucs un petit peu
parce que
c'est très joli mais bon en fait
oui en plus je peux jouer pour AB1 là
oui ça et puis je sais pas
j'avais peur au début mes tours c'est un
ça doit tenir la boutique
pas grand chose j'ai envie de dire
un peu dans la même veine que la
variante de tout à l'heure où il essaie
C3 dès le départ bon on laisse toujours
heureusement j'ai tourcé un parce que
sinon ça pouvait être le drame mais
c'est parti
je leur donne grande forest
bon il avait joué parfaitement et c'est
pris quand même une idée assez
incroyable
même en juin les coups parfait vous
voyez que quand vous êtes contrat d'où
ça toi
il arrive à trouver des idées pour
éviter de se faire égaliser la tête et
on rappelle évidemment les joueurs n'ont
pas les ordis et du coup ils connaissent
pas l'évaluation de la position alors là
on a ils ont pas la jauge donc c'est
juste du ressenti sur les positions du
calcul dans ma 4G là on s'y attendait
vraiment il y a rien
ils prennent là ça commence bien
la position
parce que il doit avoir l'impression
d'avoir joué les coups dans l'ouverture
et puis il a déjà un truc
qui voulait pas très clairement voilà
mon cavalier B8 bloqué
c'est
[Musique]
l'équivalent quasiment d'un langage
décisif j'ai envie de dire parce que le
coup de tour de 8 donne vraiment pas
envie en fait se mettre derrière le pion
faible ok ça me permet de jouer car dès
cet endroit peut-être mais bon c'est
vraiment le genre de coup moche qu'on
veut éviter quoi à ce niveau là
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de en fait tu
as tellement de problèmes à régler
comme le jouet sans doute mais par
défaut
ce qui a vraiment pas d'autre solution
j'ai l'impression
pour des villes quand même parce que
c'est un coup désagréable et maintenant
d'où ça t'aura fait il a quand même un
problème c'est pas si facile de jouer
ses positions là tout aussi donc c'est
une position très avantageuse mais tu
sais que ça s'évapore vite ce genre
d'avantage donc faut quand même être
précis que le noir bon menace de sortir
à terme de leur coquille du Tour à 7 du
cavalier 17 et je m'en sors à peu près
donc
il y a quand même ces trois minutes au
temps qui risque de compter là pour
cette offre c'est pas si simple après un
incrément c'est pas comme là
comme des piles quoi
on va réussir à libérer ce cavalier
et j'ai envie de dire qu'il sait pas
trop trop mal alors ça n'a pas trop mal
sorti hein je crois
sortir le cavalier BIM il l'a fait
direct
il s'est pas amusé à les prendre ces
trois qu'est-ce qu'il essaie qui allait
prendre des 6 qui laissait les pièces
actives
le matériel c'était pas urgence là
c'était vraiment l'activité je crois que
le CNIT a coupé
c'est le même lien
non OK
a gagné contre Collard de la première
partie pour ensuite égaliser juste
derrière et gagner l'armée
il avait deux parties hyper
intéressantes malheureusement il a perdu
les deux mais direct une gaffe amateur
de coups et l'autre gaffe une pièce pour
un coup alors qu'il avait la partie
première gaffe plus de temps mais c'est
vrai qu'il avait dominé le bout en bout
et la deuxième il avait quand même plus
de temps elle était quand même vraiment
encore moins belle on va voir ces quatre
sans doute et maintenant bon c'est un
petit plus blanc mais le fou G7 est
quand même très actif donc ça risque de
pas être suffisant mais il va tourner
comme tu l'as dit peut tourner des
heures
un petit H3 un jour quand même pour
faire attention
[Musique]
c'est 4 à être pas trop de partir comme
ça
et
avant de Forest ce qui peut savoir
que tu peux voir
essayer de te créer un pion passé aussi
faire des choses
d'ailleurs ici
parce qu'il faut faire gaffe aussi si tu
déconnes un petit peu avec les Noirs
genre tu sais le tour 8 il y a des tours
B6 après qui peuvent arriver et on peut
se faire travailler sur les deux
faiblesses et c'est
beaucoup plus longtemps
tu peux manger enfin tu peux manger
manger à 6
tu bouges pas en fou et puis je vais me
tourner en B2 et là je commence à gagner
l'initiative
enfin la vitesse ils font ça comme
c'était archi normal
et surtout la vitesse qui est
impressionnante
pour mes 8 excellent
ben là c'est une partie de très haut vol
il a compris tout de suite
le retard de développement qu'il avait
avant de Forest
encore une fois devant autant dans les
deux parties il a souffert peut-être
dans la première mais là il est quand
même devant autant
comme tu l'as dit sauf on avait parlé
mais en fait ce n'était pas un mystique
il a juste complètement raté le matin
donc tour B8 comment est-ce qu'on va
jouer ici dans on va devoir échanger
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que les Noirs j'ai un
peu moins mais
passons que bon là je perdais 600 en
fait on va se on va faire un peu
attention à pas donner le pion mais tu
vois de manière générale
non mais dans l'idée
[Musique]
mais bon
tu sens que ça casse gueule
j'ai pris la colonne B madame qui sont
de chez qui mon fou qui est hyper fort
d'activités et c'est pas du tout tu vois
à la base ce qui est marrant dans la
partie c'est que avec les blancs en
jouant cavalier C3 en argent ce coup là
qui va me jouer cavaler ces trois là et
bien il aurait plus de cavaler à 3 et
avoir une position qui était juste
normale et on va aussi travailler ces
trois et bien il a sacrifié un pion qui
n'a pas été accepté d'ailleurs
pour l'activité et maintenant et ben à
la fin on est dans une position du même
style sauf que là c'est le noir qui vont
offrir le pion au blanc ou d'ailleurs
d'un point assez joli jouer de la part
des
des blancs si je prends là
le faux mauvais coups donc je peux pas
jouer
[Musique]
des matchs de couloir et faire tourner
un et ramener mais c'est très long pas
de passage
[Musique]
et après le bouffe
mais bon ok c'est
il y a eu un coup attends
je vais par les noirs et où H6 a été
joué encore Paradou qui fait encore un
coup un coup brillant et surtout pas
le coup brillant parce que c'est le coup
normal vu son idée précédente le coup
brillant c'était plutôt dame prend à 6 à
la limite
parce que c'est très chaud cette
position en fait
et que c'est correct ah d'accord je
pense
elle est pas prenable et ben il
considère
[Musique]
il fait un coup brillant
il y a beaucoup d'après car on ajoute
[Musique]
donc là il y a de la pression sur les
deux pièces là mutuelles mais les pièces
peuvent pas se manger
sinon
ouais bah je peux enlever ma tour de B8
pour vraiment menace la prendre quoi
d'ailleurs faut que je protège mon pion
des 6 aussi je fais ça donc tour des 8
ça paraît plus normal que
toi
mais bon j'ai quand même mon activité
de départ qui est toujours présente quoi
très compliqué
mais c'est chaud les deux rois sont un
petit peu il y a eu tout revu
le coup embêtant et du coup qu'est-ce
qu'il a prévu parce que ça fait peur
parce que là tu menaces des
comme tu commences à menacer certaines
choses quand même et surtout tu reprends
un vieux qui me fait peur sauf parce que
je peux jouer
un tour prend un deux donc c'était vu
par Van forest pour bébé tous les coins
les mecs
c'était ça la
pointe je l'ai vu parce que c'était
affiché avant
une fois le rayon X
peut-être qu'il a raté van forest parce
qu'il a cru que B8
il serait vraiment bien et du coup
B8 donc bon je joue prends un F2 même si
le jeu
tour à 8
6 qui va traîner quelque part là leur
prise prise et
non
[Musique]
du couloir donc là c'est le moment clé
mais il va
bon il suffit d'être un petit peu
appliqué dans cette position peut-être
on va pouvoir
intercaler le petit coup gagnant
que là quand on a
on a la main on a la main on a tout de
bon
qui doit surveiller toujours le mal du
couloir
S
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce qui voulait c'est juste voilà
il s'est trompé aussi comme quoi même
lui
a oublié faut H4 quelque chose mais bon
lui il est molotants donc gros
retournement ou avec le temps qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait jouer sauf sur F5 est-ce
qu'on aurait pu
trouver quelque chose c'est bien battu
van forest ça c'est sûr donc pas d'ici
s'il fallait jouer comment gagner
le travail
[Musique]
sur ce coup-là
il a oublié de manger la pièce avec nous
en Jaguar on voit les les maths mais il
y avait la tour qui peut revenir en fait
partie il a fait une super partie et bon
en plus vent de Forest avait pas fait
beaucoup de bêtises et là c'est en train
en plus de pouvoir
ça peut merder même ça pour abusa torov
parce que ils peuvent vouloir
véritablement gagner cette partie peut
encore d'ailleurs mais il faut pas qu'il
en fasse trop
ça peut se retourner
bon quand même c'est lui qui a la main
pour prendre et comment tu empêche tous
ces
[Musique]
tu vas pouvoir le jouer mais je peux
mettre mon four en D8 plutôt que ma tour
à 8
il faut que je bouge ça
et sur ça à faire ça
fout des 8 in extremis après je
rapproche mon roi vite vite
4 minutes pour le pour les noirs qui
sont en défense mais tu vois il a un
plan de plus qu'un main contre le reste
il y en a un pion de plus qui veut dire
que
si va trop loin et ben il peut perdre en
fait
que même le manque de temps pour ça
Torah devrait lui permettre avec le
rajout de temps de tenir cette position
en plus
il va monter le roi et même peut-être
bon
c'est nul
il va peut-être essayer un petit quelque
chose
oui je peux jouer tour C8 toujours
et là je défends de toi je fais tourner
D8 comme ça je gagne un chat et puis
voilà on va voir quelque chose comme
dans ce goût là
même si ça d'où ça t'aura fait etc il y
a pas d'histoire je joue bien sûr il a
il est il est beaucoup mieux autant et
s'il mange des cèpes ben écoute il a un
peu plus
ouais donc du coup faut 5 et roi E6
après je vais faire ça de là
[Musique]
ok
il va jouer 4 a priori
et puis l'autre problème
h ne gagne pas donc c'est encore un
facteur annulant qui permet de
liquidation
et là maintenant vous voyez que dans
cette position vous êtes obligé de jouer
F4 si vous voulez gagner un moment
et tous ces changements donc là il y a
aucune raison de perdre cette position
il peut jouer plein de coup de fou plein
de coup de fou c'est nul voilà
donc ça va faire deux
balles
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un craquage
d'abdos à torrent on peut le dire même
si c'est un joueur génial il avait tout
fait et il a oublié mais la pression du
temps
c'était magnifique il a oublié de manger
en fait il y a eu ce thème
de
il y a
comment ça marche
il y a tout un
tour on gagne la première rangée et une
fois que tu es là bah tu peux jamais
manger là parce que pour moi du couloir
aussi et en fait dans la partie dame F6
pour menacer matelas
s'en foutait
4 ben je peux pas manger ici parce que à
la fin il y a toujours cette histoire de
maths du match je peux faire ce que je
veux je peux manger
un F2 ce sera la même histoire à la fin
il y a toujours tout un échec si je
prends un 8 aussi en premier c'est la
même chose la même histoire dès que je
mange F2 il mange et là c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs de montrer tout
reprend F2 quand il y a la dame en F6
parce que c'est ce thème là qu'il faut
bien voir
parce que c'est un peu comme dans la
partie
3 F2 et c'est Dame prend dam qui va être
le déclencheur du gain en fait parce que
là maintenant on se reprend tout droit
il a vu ça torrent et la synthétiser les
éléments et du coup il a fait une petite
pirouette qu'on avait pas vu c'est ce
dame F3 Souf
qui est hyper malin dans la partie
du coup ici
dans la partie
oups
3 qui va venir
et il a joué
on peut ramener la tour et c'est marrant
parce que sur F5
il a oublié de prendre un F2 et ça c'est
et s'il avait joué d'un point F2 madame
défend la case E1 de ma du couloir donc
il y a ça marche pas du tout moi le fou
a été abandonné
il vient de comprendre il a regardé il a
regardé d'où ça t'auras pourquoi
ce qui pensait être gagnant n'a pas
gagné et il vient de s'apercevoir
qu'il a
raté un gain immense stouf et du coup
bah il y en a claqué la porte de chez
lui
il est encore pas en danger hein il a
ils ont fait deux nuls il reste encore
deux parties plus éventuellement
d'Armageddon donc pas du tout pas du
tout mal à avance donc tout va bien quoi
[Rires]
non c'est une petite pause parce que
François vient d'arriver et pas tout
vient d'arriver donc on est obligé de
faire une petite pause salut à tous ceux
qui arrivent et à bientôt et d'ici trois
minutes je reviens pour la troisième
partie de cette petite finale entre 20
Forest et Abdou santorov donc à tout de
suite et à toi bah je te dis ben bon
courage pour ta dans la partie de enfin
dernier match bien sûr de badminton fait
honneur
théorie on te laisse partir maintenant
il faut gagner et tu nous raconteras un
peu tes exploits et puis bah écoute
j'espère que ça va bien marcher
prochaine et que c'est aussi bon courage
pour le Top 16 parce que je crois qu'on
se retrouve
merci ouais ça démarre dès mercredi
prochain pour elle le suivre sur
Internet évidemment ce Top 16 avec les
meilleurs français et je parle pas de
moi évidemment donc du coup ça va être
bien dur est-ce compétition c'est bien
mais on va se faire plaisir on va se
faire plaisir on a expliqué avec Stef
qu'on aimait jouer les forts joueurs
donc ça va être l'occasion et après faut
pas se cagouler parce que c'est
voilà bon en tout cas tout à l'heure
enfin à bientôt Kevin
pour pour se dénouement avec abusa torov
qui est un peu greenfouf va falloir qui
se refasse à tout de suite tout de suite
bye performance
[Musique]
je suis de retour tout seul
malheureusement un Kévin qui nous a
lâchement abandonné pour aller jouer au
badminton il avait un match de base
c'était prévu depuis
un bon moment à un pas de souci donc à
la place et ben je le mets des belles
chaussures j'espère que vous préférez
les chaussures à Kevin en tout cas vous
vous donnerez vos vos ressentis
à la fin du stream ainsi vous préférez
les chaussures ou Kevin moi j'ai déjà ma
petite idée en tête donc la partie 3 qui
a commencé depuis déjà quelques minutes
je suis un petit peu en retard je suis
désolé
on va essayer de rattraper un petit peu
le retard de cette partie voir ce qui
s'est passé depuis le début donc pour
l'instant le score c'est 1-1 il y a eu
deux matchs nuls il reste deux parties
encore à jouer
donc standard
accepter et tout ça c'est assez
standard donc Abdou qui joue très solide
cette position
ok il faut froid qui coule cavalier et
on va jouer à trois pour jouer dans ces
deux
et un problème sur la sur la colonne
vis-à-vis avec du B4 éventuellement ici
qui va être possible et aussi un pion en
E5 qui contrôle aussi la case F6 et la
case D6
ça donne des idées éventuellement de
jouer un jour d'écoute comme cavalier 4
et 5 ou c'était un peu sur ces cases là
avec un tour des un qui peut aussi sympa
sympa pour les blancs
on aurait pu avoir quelque chose
d'encore mieux que les chaussures mais
ça n'a pas pu se faire les gens
aujourd'hui je suis un peu déçu en vrai
[Musique]
c'est du rapide les joueurs sont déjà
fatigués en se fait un moment qui joue
déjà donc voilà faut pas trop trop
et on peut blender dans cette position
où les blancs peuvent mettre la pression
c'est pas évident faut faire attention
l'idée derrière ce coup de faire tout
enfin
j'aime beaucoup alors pourquoi dans 8
premièrement il y a un vis-à-vis sur la
colonne c'est il y a du B4 profitant de
vis-à-vis qui est tout le temps un petit
peu
en question et avec dames à 8 et ben on
va mettre une batterie sur la diagonale
H1 A8 et la dame en plus c'est un peu
caché donc elle est bien placée à 8 et
contre le huitième rangée la diagonale
et elle s'est enlevée du vis-à-vis de la
colonne c'est donc c'est ça c'est un
plan qui est hyper standard pour toutes
les positions de de
gambidame comme ça regardez d'ailleurs
votre forest qui fait la même je me
demande s'il a envie de faire dames
c'est pas c'est la même idée parce que
il y a un pion en E5 donc généralement
tu mets pas une dame derrière un pion
comme ça c'est un peu moche donc l'idée
de dame B1 peut être B4 parce que le
vis-à-vis maintenant est clair parce que
position avec damso2 B4 pas possible
parce qu'on peut prendre enfin c'est pas
mes 4 et Ben est une est une est un coup
d'utiliser parce que d'un point C8 je
peux manger deux fois la dame alors que
maintenant après d'un bain et ben je
peux faire dans la 8 et m'enlever de
cette colonne et Madame sont toujours
pas mal placé sur la diagonale en tout
cas j'aime bien l'idée de la 8 a été
joué par Abdou bien évidemment à bloqué
on lui a soufflé
à couper son micro parce que je pense
qu'il pourrait vraiment tricher pour
pour écouter les coups de tout vous
savez tout à ce jeu
un cabinet est parti et ça y est je
pense je pars en cacahuète bon dans ma
vie de tous les 7 ça c'est normal mais
comment on continue maintenant bien elle
s'est mise là pour jouer B4 j'imagine un
profitant du vis-à-vis mais comment je
continue après dans ma parce que B4
je suis trop de fois dessus
[Musique]
soit j'ai 3 pour jouer à 4 donc là on en
parlait un de G3 alors on va imaginer
que les Noirs jouent pas juste pour voir
un petit peu le plan que pourrait avoir
ici les blancs pH4 quand G8 et ben je
peux avoir des idées de style cavallée
gs5 et donc je menace de manger H7 et
sur G6 il a plein de choses qui peuvent
arriver en tout cas c'est intéressant ça
fait des trous sur quatre mois aussi et
sur faut ranger 5 ben je pensais à h3G 5
celui de roi là tour là et tapé sur H7
bon maintenant qu'il y a une batterie
sur la diagonale ça devient un peu
compliqué de faire je crois pour les
Noirs mais ça reste quand même une idée
et il y a aussi
prend H4 ben maintenant je reviens un
temps avec G3 et orange et 2 et j'arrive
très vite à la taxe sur H7 donc c'est
aussi une possibilité en tout cas ça
fait deux choses qui étaient
intéressantes et ici l'affaire H3 H3 H6
x 1 parfois c'est assez étrange
j'imagine que pour un il veut peut-être
essayer de jouer en P4 B4 c'est un coup
qui est encore tout en sa range ici
imaginons que je passe mon temps avec
les Noirs
j'essaie de chercher à comprendre un peu
pour prendre mes 4
pour y avoir pour prendre une
possibilité il a pu en prendre j'attaque
là
[Musique]
je pense ça marchera bien
pourquoi on est cinq
voilà fatigué là on a un peu
l'ordinateur
et je prends en B4 si tu manges du pion
je pensais faire
mon coup je suis rassuré parce que
j'avais pensé à cette idée là avant par
contre là le coup E6 l'ordinateur ça
j'ai pas du tout imaginé c'est un peu
difficile bref c'est des positions
difficiles mais je pense que B4 devait
être l'idée de 23 reste et c'est pour ça
qu'ici les Noirs ont joué à 5 pour
essayer de de d'empêcher les cadres la
table donc c'est un peu bizarre ce qui
nous fait ce qui nous fait ici van
forest donc déjà on voit un couple qui a
deux points d'interrogation avoir un peu
ce qui se passe mais avant ça on voit
regarder la suite de coups des blancs
c'est assez bizarre il vient de jouer
dame B1 H3 ou 1 et 2
donc clairement il y a un problème dans
la position
des blancs c'est pas quoi faire et sur
cavaler 3 c'est le coup qui a deux
points d'exclamation et c'est quoi
l'idée
sur F3 il y avait un problème de
surcharge je pense notamment qui peut
pas tout défendre tout reprendre
un je prends E4 sur tam31 je prends E4
dans tous les cas les Noirs vont réussir
à récupérer leurs pièces et en plus en
prime on aura un bon fou contre un fou
complètement
dégueulasse en un donc ça va être très
mauvais pour avoir le reste qui
risque de perdre cette partie
il y a une fourchette sur le chéquier
enfin
j'ai l'impression quand même que
et sur elle reprend E3
regarde en fait je pense c'est perdu en
ligne
cette partie
qui est la meilleure suite mais
je ne serai pas à Chartres François
je serai pas à ça du tout
je ne suis pas encore autant de bugger
désolé
j'ai pas à Chartres
[Musique]
avec mon équipe avec mon club on s'est
qualifié pour le Top 16 mais l'année
prochaine en 2024 dire que là notre
saison à nous est terminée et l'année
prochaine en 2024 on sera en Top 16 mais
cette année je ne suis pas encore en Top
16 la saison 2 N1 c'est terminé mais la
saison de Top 16 n'a pas commencé encore
2023 donc je sais pas du tout où est-ce
que le Top 16 ça va organiser en 2024
dans tous les cas je serai sûrement
j'espère
que tu es fort j'espère que je serai
pris
je pense que normalement oui et
dans ce cas là et ben je serai présent
l'année prochaine au Top 16 donc je
pourrais voir Laurent Freyssinet je
pourrais voir Kevin
Kevin sérieux je pourrais avoir aussi
Fabienne toute la team commentateur
cheesecom sans oublier aussi vous savez
que le club de le club de de Samy et
Nathan donc nos deux gros modos
cheesecom et ben seront aussi et sur
place parce que leur équipe c'est aussi
qualifié pour le Top 16 l'année
prochaine dans une torsion de poule donc
l'année prochaine il y aura Sami il y
aura Nathan il y aura Libye il y aura
Laurent il y aura Kevin et il y aura
tout on va tous être en top 5 l'année
prochaine ça va être beau ça va être
beau
bien que quelqu'un qui se dévoue pour
commenter le top 7 l'année prochaine
mais on sera tous partis donc avoir
je suis aussi que par rapport à vos
commentaires qui sont le chat j'ai mis
de délai il va dire que quand vous
écrivez sur le chat le message je le
vois instantanément par contre la
réponse vous la voyez une minute après
que je donnais ma réponse en fait si
décalage de twitch
il nous est inhumé imposé pour ce
tournoi donc voilà malheureusement
malheureusement
c'est pour ça que on a un petit peu de
malade à discuter on a un petit peu en
décalé mais mais en tout cas voilà seul
les amis sont pris je suis pas encore
remis mais là ça y est j'ai jamais
jamais été aussi proche de toute ma vie
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
partie
il a fait la sacrifié la à la dame pour
plusieurs pièces bon tant qu'à faire il
est foutu il tente des choses
et là matériellement j'ai mangé quoi
j'ai mangé une tour et un four pour la
dame maintenant il y a ça en prise sans
prise ça intéresse en ce qui nous fait
si je mange une tour il va sûrement
vouloir récupérer la dame donc je vois
un cavalier F6 si je mange du pion je
mange là
et si je prends genre là et là
que je mange par exemple là
trois quatre cinq six sept chacun plus
et la colle ouverte ça a l'air durant il
faut que l'opposé mais bon plus il y a
plein de lignes il y a eu un F6
d'ailleurs
un S6
on va aller prendre un
ouais
c'est encore mieux c'est encore mieux
c'est encore mieux
donc voilà c'est terminé
il y a deux pions plus net pour
pour ici
encore une fois la seule chance de
vendre forest cette partie la seule
chance c'est que
en cas de d'échange de de fou de tour
pardon et ben il y a des chances de
nulle vous avez quand on va poser il y a
quand même pas mal de nuls donc après ça
à voir c'était pas du tout si c'est
possible ou pas
depuis on s'est quand même beaucoup donc
si je joue très très vite il met la
pression
et là tu MP3 alors à l'art perdu parce
qu'il apparaît ici B4 j'ai trop de pions
qui vont avancer
et ça a l'air ça a l'air complètement
fini c'est moi les commenter de stouffe
de supporters
franchement c'était non parti de la part
de vente forest je pense qu'il y a
complètement blender alors là il y a eu
je vous rappelle une partie une
ouverture assez standard mais là il y a
eu une série de coups très étranges de
la part de mon forest ici et en fait a
fait que regarder il a joué dam bien H3
x
= C2 et quand toujours plein de coups
bizarres comme ça à un moment donné j'ai
envie de dire
ben tu te prends souvent des tactiques
il a la tactique bon c'est un peu
compliqué tout ça mais au final ça perd
et donc ça fait 2-1 pour pour cette
offre alors je vais vous mettre
maintenant je vais vous changer les
petits les petits scores
et tout ça pour la dernière partie
alors ça va la partie ou pas en fait
parce que
parce que si votre forest gagne
maintenant avec les Blancs et ben on
sera à égalité avec deux et
il y aura un Armageddon donc pour
l'Armageddon c'est assez simple comment
ça se passe je vais vous changer
lors des caméras
et hop j'aime beaucoup ce petit ce petit
programme que j'ai là un programme qu'on
m'a mis un zoom Bridge qui est génial
pour faire tout ça et donc oui en fait
alors pour les pour la magazine si
jamais il y en a un et ben c'est assez
marrant parce que alors magasin de
manière générale ça se fait en blitz et
on a 5 minutes contre six minutes le
joueur qui a 6 minutes c'est le joueur
qui a les
c'est le joueur qui a les blancs
et en fait il a obligation de gagner
avec une banque qui a plus de temps mais
il est obligé de gagner en comparaison
les noirs et ben ils ont moins de temps
donc ils ont 5 minutes c'est du chaos et
la nuit en cas de nul les Noirs se
qualifierait ça c'est normal mais en
fait en tournant vu que c'est des
cadences en 15 + 3 et ben ils ont voulu
garder une cadence quand même assez
longue et pour la farine enfin pour la
magazine de ce tournoi ça c'est marrant
en fait et ben il y a une sorte
d'enchère ça veut dire que les deux
joueurs vont écrire à l'arbitre quel
temps ils veulent et le joueur qui
marque le temps le plus bas aura les
noirs avec le temps qu'il aura écrit par
exemple hier on a vu on a eu on
assistait à un magasin
et l'Armageddon c'était entre filles et
Colars Colars avec les 9 30 et
si vous avez marqué 8-25 un truc comme
ça et donc entre 9h30 et le 25 le plus
bas c'est 825 donc fearus là qui est
proposé 8-25 a gagné l'enchère donc
aller noir par contre Ben il va avoir 8
minutes 25 contre 15 minutes voilà
et la baignoire et il sait que s'il fait
nuit et ben nul ou plus et ben il gagne
et ce qualifie malheureusement il a
perdu la partie et il se peut qualifié
mais voilà aujourd'hui on a aussi eu
un magazon entre Jules Moussa donc Jules
qui est venu après sur la chaîne
vraiment très sympa Jules et Collard
c'est encore le même
donc Collard sans surprise il est encore
je prends 9 29 exactement tandis que
tandis que Jules avait mis 10-47 donc 10
47 vues a dit ok 47 la condition d'avoir
beaucoup de temps généralement
11 et donc avec une meuf 29 et ben c'est
Colars qui a gagné moins cher donc là et
par contre avec 29 contre 15 minutes et
la cadence en plus c'est du chaos enfin
il y a pas de rajout de temps donc c'est
du chaos et Jules a gagné très
brillamment cette partie
sur l'échiquier voilà finale avec avec
un pion de plus les fous de même couleur
donc donc Jules d'ailleurs si vous
voulez en faire un point classement si
vous voulez regarder donc classement il
est il est ici je vais vous le mettre
dans un instant garder hop donc le
classement est ici alors pour l'instant
tout est à jour
dans la poudre des gagnants qui se
trouve en haut à gauche et ben on a pour
l'instant App Store qui est enfin qui
gagne 2 1 et encore une partie à jour
donc
ça fera 2 il y aura marmage
sera qualifié pour la grande finale en
grande finale il manque des joueurs vous
allez voir qu'en dessous
karwana et Moussa donc Jules
joueront demain à partir de 17h et le
gagnant de ce match car wanna et Jules
affrontera le looser final loser final
c'est qui c'est le joueur qui a perdu la
finale c'est traduction facile et le
joueur qui a perdu la finale ce sera du
coup on imagine van forest donc
imaginons que demain Jules gagne Jules
Peugeot 60 Forest en demi-finale
pour se qualifier pour la grande finale
contre le grand gagnant qui serait à toi
donc en tout cas c'est comme ça que se
déroule le tournoi si vous voulez on
peut jeter un œil aussi pour les prix
les prix sont comme oups les prix je
pensais avoir les prix ont disparu
madame de Monsieur
c'est le prix donc par contre ça c'est
pas le prix
c'est le prix de la pâte finale
on avait pris la Division 2
on avait aussi la division 3 mais il y
avait aussi des prix
propre au tournoi en fait là il y a une
série de plein de tournois si vous
voulez et après je vous montre le vrai
prix à 30 000 au premier Division 1
20000 au deuxième 15e bref les prix sont
assez énormes et donc Julie il est pas
mal hein Jul il est pas mal pour
l'instant donc petite finale je pense
lui irait bien dans tous les cas on lui
on lui souhaite mais demain il faut
qu'il passe
Carona et quand même un adversaire qui
est extrêmement sérieux
carbonara sont débutants il a battu
shimanov 2 et demi il a perdu contre App
Store 1 et demi à deux et demi et
ensuite il est venu jouer contre furuzac
aujourd'hui et demain il affronter Jules
donc un autre Français d'affilée et
alors que je lui trouve aussi un bon
tournoi il a perdu
il est vraiment très fort et derrière il
a le shimanov qui a mis 2-0 et Collard
de 1 donc Jul pour l'instant il fait un
tournoi un parcours plutôt cool et
demain je contre kerwana ça a vraiment
être la fiche de la journée donc donc
voilà on va revenir à notre scène avec
les parties on va voir si
la partie a commencé la dernière partie
de la journée je l'ai pas encore dans la
partie la partie là on va commencer les
jeux à envoyer les joueurs ils sont en
train de s'installer on voit on voit
clairement ici que
que Abdou s'installe on ne me reste fait
la sieste et salut c'est ce qu'on va
faire je sais pas qui est-ce qu'on va
faire je pense que c'est Nathan
sur 5000 comme ça
il aurait pas fait ça je reconnais trop
à l'orthographe
et
[Musique]
et les chaussures oui alors j'ai caché
regardez les chaussures c'est un petit
montage que j'ai fait pour cacher
l'absence de Kevin qui est parti au bad
et
donc
voilà voilà et ensuite alors oui tout à
l'heure tu étais pas là mais on m'a
parlé du Top 16 parce que j'ai souhaité
acquérir en partant bon courage pour le
Top 16 il va partir de mercredi prochain
il va il va il va jouer pour son club
donc de Mulhouse et
on m'a donné dans le chat si je
participais aussi au top 7 cette année
donc je leur ai dit que non mon club
c'est qualifié avec brio cette année en
gagnant son groupe de national donc
l'année prochaine on va être en Top 16
mais pour la saison 2024 et j'ai aussi
cité ton club c'est Nathan et j'ai dit
aussi que l'année prochaine en Top 16 il
y aura beaucoup de monde dans de jazz
commun il y aura il y aura Sami il y
aura toi il y aura Fabien
il y aura
Laurent il y aura
Kevin il y aura bien sûr Mathieu cornet
tu verras bien sûr Sébastien Mazet
il y aura bien sûr tout bien sûr et il y
aura tout le monde en fait et
c'est cool il y a plus de Fatou pas tout
il faut que
qu'est-ce qu'elle est ici aussi avec son
club je crois que Fatou vient de gagner
aussi son groupe il me semble que quel
était en National je crois et je crois
que son club a gagné la Nationale 2 Sims
si je me trompe pas donc peut-être
d'après un Fatou qui gagne la nationale
et qui vient monter aussi en Top 16 avec
nous
mais en vrai c'est cool et d'ailleurs ça
pourrait être sympa de commenter pour
moi en fait parce qu'au final le Top 16
il y a tellement de gens qu'on connaît
que c'est toujours très sympa de pouvoir
suivre ces événements en français avec
plein de joueurs français que vous
connaissez donc donc avoir en tout cas
ça se fait cette année je crois que ça
va chevaucher avec le norwatchesse mais
je crois qu'il y a trois jours à la fin
donc avoir en tout cas si c'est possible
de faire
Kevin descends
Kevin trop solide non pas plus Mulhouse
c'est quand même costaud l'équipe de
Mulhouse ça rigole pas trop quand même
généralement c'est une belle équipe donc
après je sais pas trop j'ai pas encore
regardé j'ai hâte de voir de voir la
grille un petit peu des vélos voir un
peu comment ça se passe
voir les forces de chaque équipe c'est
[Musique]
toujours hyper intéressant de voir quel
équipe est forte quelle équipe tout ça
ça m'intéresse vachement surtout qu'en
plus l'année prochaine avec mon club et
ben je vais y être donc
[Musique]
Fatou dans deux ans et c'est à nous qui
va te dire maintenant ça qui va pas être
facile ouais pas de facile mais je pense
dans mon groupe dans notre groupe de N1
dans lequel j'étais je pense que c'est
plus dur de gagner le groupe de N1 que
tu vas tenir en Top 16 je pense
parce que mon groupe prendra
on a gagné mais chaque année on tente de
le gagner et chacun on arrive deuxième
on est abordé au deuxième place chez
nous il y a toujours un club qui vient
avec tous les grands maîtres et
[Musique]
dans le sud-est de la France
tu as toujours des clubs tu avais Monaco
tu avais à l'époque qui qui mettait
plein de joueurs très fortes avec club
de Nice aussi tu as deux clubs à Nice
donc les deux clubs d'efforts
qui était très très fort aussi
il y a le club de grâce qui joue tout le
temps les troubles fêtes il y a aussi
Marseille qui était là il y a
Aix-en-Provence il y a H1 toujours aussi
bon j'en sais pas dans le sud-est mais
ils sont avec nous dans le groupe et tu
avais Lyon aussi qui sont montés on a
vraiment un groupe difficile en un an
donc chaque fois chaque année il y en a
toujours un qui est là et qui veut
monter quoi quand un club qui a de
l'argent et qui veut monter ben il
achète des joueurs et en fait il
donc on est content de pouvoir être
monté en tout cas notre équipe de jeunes
et
donc on est très content après le top ça
c'est dur hein mais je pense que le
maintien en tant que c'est plus facile
que la montante 16 dans mon groupe voilà
après ouais les groupes étaient un petit
peu c'est pas très équitable en top 7 il
y a des groupes qui étaient plus faciles
que d'autres
et mais bon ok la calife c'est la calife
c'est le but
et l'année prochaine il faut maintenir
d'ailleurs l'année prochaine serait cool
enfin on va voir avec avec
Laurent mais je crois que Laurent il
voulait qu'on s'affronte
une légende en français un genre qui a
été qui a été 200700 quasiment 30 et
l'eau c'est un joueur c'est c'était top
première top 35 40 mondiales donc
toujours toujours trop cool de pouvoir
affronter le genre aussi fort en fait
donc même si bon on sait qu'on va faire
le café ça normalement pas trop trop de
surprise de suspense non plus mais qu'on
l'expliquait avec avec Kevin dans
lesquels très content d'affronter des
joueurs très forts ça commence
très content d'apprent très fort
parce que bah c'est cool de les jouer
simplement t'as rien à perdre moi demain
je contrôle Laurent
si je perds c'est normal et si je perds
pas c'est l'exploit quoi peu importe mon
résultat c'est un exploit donc
on joue ce plaisir je rencontre un
joueur qui qui a été top mondial et puis
et puis on s'amuse
et on apprend aussi donc c'est vraiment
dans cette
[Musique]
optique là qu'on va qu'on va joindre on
va essayer de se maintenir on va essayer
de progresser et de se faire plaisir et
surtout ça il faut faire
donc à vous autora cette fois-ci qui
vient le cavalier F3
et qui joue pour l'instant une position
assez solide donc est indienne avec
trois fougères et réputé pour être
extrêmement solide pour pour les blancs
et ici je me rappelle que les Noirs
c'est bon de Forest il a l'obligation de
gagner pour arriver
au départage
donc descendre jouer ici
par les blancs
de démarrer
à 5 B3 ici un coup il y a cette
thématique c'est assez simple un coup
qui est assez normal ici c'est position
on se peut dans une sorte de Benny
donc c'est 5 je pense que c'est le coup
ici en tout cas j'ai beaucoup de
position dans ce type là c'est 5 OK
déjà battu en longue non je pense que tu
parles de Laurent route l'orange une
seule fois dans ma vie
en fait non Laurent je l'ai joué deux
fois dans ma vie une fois ils ont suivi
un pas
mais une fois une fois en ces jours en
tête
et ça s'est mal passé pour lui je crois
que tu t'en souviens pas votre ami
Laurent
d'ailleurs je voulais pas je voulais pas
rappelé enfin il faudrait que je lui
rappelle que je lui ressorte la partie
quoi alors mais sinon sinon une fois en
top top 12 c'était à l'époque il y avait
eu un et moins de il y avait moins de
d'équipes que maintenant et j'avais les
noirs et il m'avait battu très propre
bon c'est pas du tout quelque chose de
d'incroyables c'est un peu normal il est
plus fort que moi bien meilleur que moi
mais j'étais assez content de le jeu et
puis après après l'analyse on avait
passé quasiment une heure à analyser
c'était
très très agréable en tout cas cette
partie 4 alors
thématique très souvent on peut
sacrifier la qualité en fait parce qu'il
sert à Caval et 4 ou 1 et un thème
tactique ici foudé deux qui va gagner
une pièce tu vois que les pièces mal
placées ici même plein de fois on peut
se permettre de sacrifier la qualité en
genre foi
G7 on va prendre et maintenant et ben on
a les cases noires mais bon voilà j'ai
quand même une tactique ou un coup qui
fait fout des deux mains et gagner ici
donc pour l'instant qui avait le 4 n'est
pas un coup mais c'est toujours dans
l'air parce que même ici comme trop bien
par exemple pour essayer de s'enlever du
vis-à-vis et ben il y aura toujours des
coups comme fou F5
parce que bah là c'est le temps bien il
faut F5 c'est quand même assez gênant
quoi
et
ici il faut
B24 sûrement c'est le bon coup aussi
donc cavalcade c'est un coup qui part
thématique et et voilà donc B5 a été
joué ok on va attaquer directement le
pion C4 avec toutes mes pièces et ici il
y a eu cavaler des quatre c'est un coup
que l'ordinateur n'aime pas trop
pour une raison que je ne connais pas
sur pion prend il y avait B4 sans doute
et le Caval il va repartir en B7 qui
avait été complètement mal placé et
c'est que le pion c'est 4 plus tard je
leur ai mangé facilement je pense
alors donc tour B8 est tombé 5 c'est la
partie et sur la princesse
sur la colonne c'est sur le pion arrière
c'est la partie B4 alors normalement
a perdu 2-0 contre karwana
les deux fois il était la première il
était gagnant il a garé un matin deux
mais bon dans le diable c'était assez
compliqué c'était une position où il est
gagnant parce que nous on a la jauge on
voit bien que la jauge elle est et puis
après on avait l'ordinateur
mais en terme de pratique en termes
d'humain c'était très extrêmement dur
pour les deux joueurs
et la deuxième partie c'est un peu
pareil sauf que c'était pas gagnant
c'est une position très compliquée il
avait une tour et deux fou pour une dame
et des pions et extrêmement compliqué et
il aurait pu gagner il aurait pu perdre
et tous les scénarios possibles et il a
donné une pièce en
donc
[Musique]
difficile en tout cas
voilà donc des quatre adultes c'est
normal et on veut plus tard essayer de
virer le cavalier qui contrôle le centre
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on veut ici
cavalier B1
ben c'est pas moi
mais
c'est très très mou comment est-ce qu'on
peut jouer avec les Blancs
en convention du Fou en échange du foot
15 blanche et de la perte de fou prise
plus tard même des B3 qui est
intéressant pour échanger les cavaliers
et avoir le contrôle total de la colonne
C j'aime bien qu'elle va dire
au début on le voit on se dit non ça
peut être bon et on passe à autre chose
mais au final quand on calcule vraiment
les goûts on se rend compte que c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que les noirs
et maintenant
la paire de fou des blancs va parler et
un super cavalent des cartes
très dangereuse
et attention je peux pas encore y aller
parce que quelqu'un peut prendre
essayer de défendre le fou B2 pour
réussir à mettre le Cavaillon C6
où je cavaler V3 alors je sais pas quel
âge je préfère
n'est plus vraiment attaqué par la
colonne C par tout ça si je prends de la
tour en C6 et Paris par jour
donc j'aime bien un plan de style ça ça
ou ça pour que je cavaler mes trois ça
me parle bien ça
j'aime beaucoup
changer les cavaliers ensemble et
apprends à taper sur ces 7 ça a l'air
cool
très vite
et très vite on a l'impression qu'il est
un peu
un petit air en tout cas
comment vas-tu
je l'ai pas vu
[Musique]
tu peux le partager sur le chat
j'ai un peu croulé dans la main écroulé
à part tout ce que je fais là j'ai mes
courses la journée derrière j'ai le
stream c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à faire
et j'ai pas le temps de voir toutes ces
beaux articles
n'hésite pas en tout cas à le partager
sur le chat si tu veux
donc
là il hésite mais je pense que la clé
c'est défendre ce fou pour je cavaler le
pétrole
bref
prendre un côté j'ai mon cavalier qui va
bloquer là j'aime pas
et puis on prend j'aime pas parce que le
pion
va sortir donc ça c'est une suite de
coup que j'avais un petit peu
un petit peu comment dire
vite
balayer parce que ça avait l'air pas
terrible et sur ça c'est quoi l'astuce
parce que je peux pas pour l'instant
ça me sert pas à grand chose de faire ça
à moins que vraiment j'ai envie de
manger la tour ici
tout le temps
[Musique]
c'est dur en fait beaucoup de moi en
fait
pour pour sortir un gaz pour bouger
en fait c'est intéressant mais bien sûr
je vais je vais pas dire que ce que fait
abdouin est pas bon mais de base je n'ai
pas la position parce que j'aimais pas
le fait de me faire informer la tour
mais quand on rentre vraiment dans la
position on se rend compte que que
les gens sont vraiment très très fortes
échecs
c'est la partie et puis on B4 va sauter
le pion va sauter je vais mettre le pion
ici en
[Musique]
A5 et à essayer d'ouvrir la position et
mon fou qui va taper sur la case de
promotion ici en 8 quoi
donc ça a l'air complètement gagnant
c'est qui ici
a le lien de la mettre là
et je la regarderai
je la regarderai après
donc qui propose maintenant pas mal de
contenu en tout cas
que soit en short ou en vidéo YouTube ou
en reportage franchement c'est cool
tondeur pour ceux qui sont sur twitch ou
sur Youtube n'hésitez pas en tout cas à
follow les chaînes à vous abonner en
tout cas pour être averti à chaque fois
qu'il y a de nouveaux contenus qui est
des vidéos qui est des Stream qui est
des événements et ben en vous abonnant
et ben vous serez avertis à chaque fois
qu'on est là et à chaque fois qu'il y a
un truc donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas à
vous abonner à vous à vous
à nous follow il y a aussi nous suivre
d'ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux on
est sur Facebook sur Twitter on est de
partout donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas à
nous suivre de partout ça fait plaisir
ça nous aide en plus
donc c'est cool cache-cache j'aime
beaucoup H4 H5 H6 tapes sur G7 c'est
vraiment vraiment cool
et d'ailleurs aussi pour ceux qui sont
qui seraient sur la chaîne et qui ne
connaissent pas ma chaîne perso
industrie je me permets ah je peux pas
faire de saut malheureusement je ne peux
pas faire le saut
ah si je peux le faire c'est pas ma
chaîne non
je peux pas le faire moi-même il y a un
modo dans le chat
peut-être comme un faire quelqu'un peut
me faire un petit saut avec avec ma
chaîne twitch vous savez que je suis sur
twitch sur YouTube sur un peu tous les
réseaux moi aussi avec
qui me connaissent pas et le stream
assez régulièrement donc là en ce moment
en ce moment c'était c'est difficile de
stream avec tout le boulot que j'ai sur
le stream et cheescom mais
en l'apprenant de streamcascom le site
en stream quasiment tous les jours sur
ma chaîne donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas
à passer me voir et on passera du bon
moment donc
aussi un abonnement par le follow hein
en tout cas pour commencer
bien sûr si vous aimez ce qu'on fait sur
la chaîne si vous n'aimez pas
vous forcer bien sûr et pour ceux qui
seraient intéressés par une contenu
qu'on fait et ben n'hésitez surtout pas
en tout cas un
affolo tout ce qu'on fait
alors prise prise dans ma c'est
logique on va essayer d'apprendre la
colonne a ainsi que la colonne B
et c'était quoi en plus c'est que dans
ce format là Abdou comme il a gagné la
première partie et ben il a pas besoin
de gagner la dernière juste on va match
nul avec les Blancs et ben il est sûr
d'arriver dans la grande finale donc
financier on a tout à l'heure que le
premier prix il est énorme ici donc déjà
bien sûr que Abdou il voulait il va les
prendre les 15000 euros ça c'est sûr et
en plus et en plus de ça
[Musique]
et en plus de ça il peut il veut gagner
parce que bah ils vont voter plus fort
quoi jeunes qui monte il a en 18 ans
et il est redoutable franchement il est
tellement clean dans cette partie c'est
assez incroyable et aussi un pion en
prise là
mais prise prise prise prise
à voir si c'est intéressant ou pas
peut-être ça peut simplifier la position
à une position plus facile à jouer et
après ta F4 qui pourrait arriver qui
peut être sympa taquet de 6 par exemple
mais j'ai quand même l'impression que tu
es noir arrive à s'activer un peu et
on n'aime pas trop laisser trop de gens
trop de gens noirs donc j'aime bien des
fois un peu tous les pions et on menace
un peu
qui a un jour pourra aussi avoir des
idées une dame là où là il est arrivé
sur la cage à 7 ans
donc plein d'idées intéressantes en tout
cas dans la 5 on se
[Musique]
on s'active on défend là on place la
tour comme ça en c'est mieux
et les noirs qui cherchent à tout prix
l'activité merci beaucoup Guillaume pour
pour le lien donc voilà pour ceux qui
viennent ce qu'on fait qui ne me
connaissent pas qui sont pas encore
follow à ma chaîne je vous invite à vous
abonner aussi est-ce que tu penses Cali
n'est pas en train de lâcher le champion
du monde
je pense pas en fait banquier il est
enfin en ce moment il est aussi patient
par par la mode
mais
bon il peut avoir d'autres centres
d'intérêt que les échecs mais je pense
pas qui qui
perd sa quand même de vue il sait que
c'est quand même un monstre de chaque
numéro de mondial merci mon 18 ans bon
je pense pas comme carrière se termine à
18 ans
donc non je pense qu'ils veulent
champion du monde et après je pense que
c'est par période surtout des fois ça
sera pas envie de travailler que
au moment que un autre moment donc je
pense pas qu'il est paru ça je pense pas
mais bon après je le trompe peut-être
mais je pense pas du tout
prise prise prise la dame de vente
forest se retrouve en prise face à toi
j'ai raté un truc peut-être aussi je
sais pas si c'est un troll ou si c'est
un truc que j'ai raté
parce que j'ai raté
qui écrit sur le chat
alors
principaux sur ma chaîne perso à moi
c'est tous les montages d'ailleurs sur
ma chaîne
donc donc voilà moi je le connais bien
c'est pas un truand ça dépend mais ça va
il est honnête qui est sérieux il est
bien
mais après
alors dame bien échec rouage 2 je pense
un fouet France pas forcément envie de
venir te clouer et sur voilà on peut
imaginer dans F5 qui viendrait essayer
d'activer un petit peu
mesdames 5 on va manger 6 pour pas
perdre ce pion
et peut-être manger c'est 7
j'aime pas ta meuf 3 en fait regardez
est-ce qu'il y a pas dans ma chambre
un peu la gueule donc je comprends que
tu es pas forcément envie de faire ça et
donc moi je pense aussi
tu as un pion de plus même si ce n'est
pas le meilleur plan du monde et ben
peut-être que c'était possible en tout
cas la finale est intéressante pour les
Noirs parce que le cavalier va dominer
le fou qui est mauvais dans la réception
donc faut croire intéressant parce que
maintenant
si on a je prends H6 je prends H5 et ben
c'est un peu la même qu'avant c'est pas
une finale donc en fait le fou la bonne
pâte est très bon le roi qui est ouvert
et il y a quelque chose
et la machine etc
salut
longtemps longtemps tu me diras qui est
lui aussi est passé à une immunitaire je
crois que t'es pas encore remis
il me semble encombrer j'imagine mais
qui a fait quasiment quatre normes
d'affilée je crois 4 84 marron un truc
comme ça et en plus bon les points et
l'eau qui vont avec donc zinzira à qui
donc j'ai 5 a été joué
G4 assez logique d'un point H5 et
surgele
et ici ben écoute il est toujours un
pion plus
pardon je dis n'importe quoi
mais c'est très très solide chez les
Blancs très solide en plus dès que pour
part il y a toujours des raisons un
petit peu sur case noir faire un peu
attention même des répétitions par
exemple sur un tour B4 avant on peut
aussi imaginer un coup comme tour C8
celui de ta recette enfin tu en C7 et on
va devoir revenir défendre en fait une
répétition peut-être possible sachant
que sachant que les blancs sont d'accord
de faire nul parce que et ben c'est la
dernière partie et qu'il mène au score
donc H6 a été joué et c'est une position
qui est juste égale je pense
mois prochain on espère avoir il manque
plus qu'un point hello je vais jouer le
16 juin le 16 juin je m'appartie et je
vais jouer normalement contre un contre
un 1500 1600 Elo
donc 1500 1600 et l'eau c'est un
rapporté
un point un point et demi et normalement
virtuellement je passerai 2400 hello
donc
[Musique]
petite blague qu'elle va les prendre
d'un pandam
attention parce que voilà Joe
excusez-moi
5 maintenant
il peut y avoir des idées voilà je
menace prise en G4 et des fois pas de
case et si je prends là j'écarte le Fou
est perdu
est-ce que est-ce que Abdou n'a pas
complètement craqué dans cette position
à bout qui a 5 minutes entre 7 minutes
comment est-ce que je me défends ici E3
peut-être
le 3 je bouge je vais où
ça ça sur moi
[Musique]
le gros blender de Abdou qui n'a pas
très content après F5 E3 je pense d'un
D21
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est c'est grâce
au cours que je te le donnerai il m'a
dit un truc pas mal de temps qu'on s'est
vu il m'a dit que à chaque fois qu'il
voulait indienne il pense au plan que je
lui ai montré incroyable
en plus ça fait longtemps enfin je pense
que je t'ai jamais entraîné en plus
j'étais encadré je t'ai pas entraîné
parce que
parce qu'avec le club de cannechec bon
tout ensemble en top jeune
championnat de France etc toujours là
mais perso que j'avais entraîné vraiment
je regarde l'attaque
ici et ici
d'ailleurs il a pris move attends il y a
un PRIMOVE roi je l'ai 8 il y avait un
petit dommage fuite
je sais pas à qui il a parlé lui-même en
tout cas on lui a mis les pets
directement
et salut à tous tu connais ta couleur le
16 06 non bah non je veux un tournoi
joue un open que je
a priori je vais être numéro 1 et l'eau
je pense être numéro 1 et l'autre
tournant pour les moins de 2400 et l'eau
et comme j'ai 2389 je pense qu'il y a
pas beaucoup de joueurs qui peuvent
arriver devant moi donc avoir mais
[Musique]
je sais pas quelle couleur j'aurais
généralement on met des blancs en
premier généralement souvent quand tu
fais ton programme d'arbitrage il te
demande est-ce que tu mets les blancs en
premier mais oui ou non généralement
mais oui
et bon qui est blanc noir contre
investissement normalement je devrais
gagner on s'en fout la couleur il faut
que la partie et bien je fais quoi
c'est tout quoi
ok bah écoutez vous voyez que
en début de match enfin en début de
partie il était au fond de son fauteuil
et là écoutez il s'est réveillé il s'est
réveillé il peut être gagnant
je pense que vous connaissez bien sûr
c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que vous connaissez
mais ça fait aussi très longtemps que
vous êtes pas vu tous les deux
et
[Musique]
très très longtemps
après je vais CAP ou des dames en fait
c'est terminé
il y a tous les pions tous les pions qui
vont tomber on voit un peu la fatigue la
fatigue là on voit Abdou qui a perdu sur
une sur une sur une absurdité
franchement
on sentait que c'était un mauvais coup
et
alors je connais en fait tu connais
parce que oui tu as une grille de
tournoi des jardins des gens qui sont
inscrits pour l'instant donc tu peux
anticiper par exemple il y a 150 joueurs
c'est que le numéro 1 va jouer contre le
numéro 75 pas de
et voilà et donc moi normalement je
comprends le genre du milieu donc j'ai
regardé à peu près c'est un petit
à moins qu'il y ait qui est 50 2400 qui
arrive qui s'inscrivent a priori je joue
à peu près un investissement 1700 grand
grand max
page 100 à
porter quoi bonjour moi je veux un vrai
espagnol un vrai espagnol et si les
Catalans sont encore mieux
quand ça danse encore mieux sinon
oui il y a besoin
du monde un des un des plus gros
potentiels je pense
ces derniers résultats en tout cas le
démontre donc on a besoin de on a aussi
goûter je crois des lambda qui est mort
irrigazi on a beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont jeunes qui ont 18 ans
entre 16 ans et 18 ans et qui même le
petit américain michera michera lui il a
13 ans quoi il a 13 ans et 2550 ok on
sait pas il y a encore plein de choses à
faire mais pour l'instant écoute pas mal
tu en as plein comme ça en tout cas à
avoir un petit peu ils font encore
il faut toujours démontrer jusqu'à la
fin donc Dame des deux apparemment c'est
une gaffe de la part de ventes forest
pourquoi est-ce que c'est une gaffe ici
apparemment dames la partie bon ok ça
reste pas facile il y a un pion de plus
pour les pour les Noirs une position qui
a l'air complètement gagnante mais les
pièces blanches sont assez actives
rapidement trouver des trucs et les
blancs on a l'impression que le roi elle
est complètement ouvert mais apparemment
c'est pas si grave et là il y a une dame
décale bien joué qui va forcer un
échange de dames prends des cartes puis
on prend des quatre et ben je suis
arrivé en B3 d'ailleurs peut-être même
encore mieux si en cas sur un coup de
cavalier tu vas pouvoir un fou à quatre
qui va déloger la tour de 8 et pouvoir
manger le 7 et là attention si ma tour
arrive à manger 7 par exemple on peut
imaginer ça pour cette tour bouge
ton concept même qu'elle va aller
prendre G3 bah j'ai envie de dire
écoutez
je vais réussir à manger le maximum de
pions et j'ai des chances de faire nul
avec les Blancs c'est pas clair du tout
pas clair du tout on Dame des quatre
dames
attention que le garder les dames ça
donne aussi du jeu pour pour les blancs
j'ai des chèques là et chaque là aussi
on peut éventuellement imaginer un jour
et ça c'est chaud même sur un coup comme
ouais 7 le coup marrant c'est un
prancissement
parce que du coup bah je suis cloué donc
non position qui devient assez chaude en
fait et avant de faire là c'était bien
il faut qu'il
gagne quoi alors toi aussi un coup
intéressant
mais est-ce que tu mates je menace échec
roi là et tout rêve de maths
est-ce que il y a moyen de faire un truc
alors j'entends
comme ça que 6 peuvent faire en fait je
pars en ligne je pars en ligne parce que
je peux pas empêcher ça
et ça enfin il y a trop de menace en
fait et là cavalier
et en plus qui bloque la colonel et sur
un coup du style G4 bon il y aura d'un
projet 4 je dis n'importe quoi et sur un
coup ou DS5 maintenant la colonne la
rangée est ouverte donc j'aurais même
dame j'ai 7 mars
donc tout réflexe c'est peut-être pas le
pas un coup génial même si ça a l'air de
faire des belles menaces mais faut F3 à
l'arc à ma sœur
qu'est-ce que j'ai
d'autres que la tour fuite c'est chaud
hein qui réfléchit beaucoup on sent un
petit peu de déception là parce que on
sent qu'il a il sait qu'il a raté
quelque chose
et
on sait pas comment vraiment continuer
il est hyper concentré
hyper concentré il donne tout ah il a le
tour est fuite donc on va voir je pense
ça il a anticipé bien sûr à ce niveau là
ça calcule tellement vite tellement bien
chez Abdou
parfois c'est la partie
et j'ai mon chat qui vient gratter à la
porte je crois qu'il a faim et oui c'est
l'heure
parfois
et là je vois pas bien les coups c'est
vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est un peu embêtant
quand même
des cinq je pense non à tout reprendre
ça je l'ai raté
voilà c'est chaud là
qui va se chachapper sur dame 2 roi F5
à la vallée
ça je peux aussi aller là
et sur dame là voilà et bon bah nul
les blancs sont contents parce que les
Blancs gagnent au score donc
[Musique]
sur G4
je m'en fous
mais roi F5 tout le monde enfin
c'est intéressant aussi
peut-être plus
donc ok comment continuer là dame
descend peut-être le 6 alors ici c'est
un coin interdit en éclouer monsieur
donc dame dessin cavaliers aussi je
t'aime F5 qui va changer les dames qui
va me faire gagner la partie et sur ça
mais bon j'ai l'impression que
ça fait nul enfin
jamais la partie et ils sont peut-être
même mieux d'ailleurs mais l'objectif
des blancs c'est pas perdre quoi
bah c'est la partie ils ont joué
ce que j'ai proposé ta mère froide à
prendre
et maintenant bah écoute je pense que ça
va faire nul
enfin je vois pas du tout en fait
gagner sa clé noir c'est improbable
donc là il faut juste être
trois je défends et là on va on va voir
une nulle malheureusement
malheureusement il y a aucun moyen de
gagner avec les Noirs donc ça fait nuit
mais il a même pas essayé de Forest on
va essayer
s'il essaie ben je sais pas j'ai autre
chose mais en fait il va perdre 7 si il
joue aussi ben il va perdre le pion h6
il est plus on pourra avancer en fait il
peut pas il peut pas essayer de gagner
quoi t'en prends des six non Cyril alors
ça je l'avais même pas vu mais c'est
vrai que donc comme le dit ça a pas
l'air bon Dame des 6 en fait ça laisse
le trait à l'adversaire le problème en
fait
alors un premier site tu veux dire ici
j'imagine parce qu'il y a un clouage
mais là tu me laisses le trait
parce que maintenant j'ai plein d'échec
peut-être que c'est un bon coup j'en
sais rien mais là
donc fait des échecs là tu laisses
mettre un adversaire on sait jamais en
pratique te prends pas la tête là tu as
un coup qui fait la dame de manière
forcée fais-le tu sais que tu que tu n'a
aucun cas où tu peux perdre cette partie
donc voilà on voit maintenant qu'ils
étaient qualifié pour la grande finale
avec zéro défait donc là je vais vous
montrer un petit peu le tableau le
bracket que qui est à jour ici une
plaquette qui est ici et il est à jour
déjà directement presque un jour ils
m'ont plus que mettre à
dans la grande finale qui s'est qualifié
donc demain on va avoir le match de
Jules Moussa contre
Fabiano carvana
qui qualifiera à la finale du braquet de
loosers les perdants contre ventes
forest qui lui vient de perdre contre
le gagnant de
Forest et l'invity mystère
se qualifiera pour jouer contre App
Store dans la grande finale et devra le
battre deux fois pour gagner l'événement
donc c'est quelque chose de très
difficile en tout cas et en tout cas bon
écoutez on a encore un Français en lice
c'est c'est Jules et Jules demain contre
contre carvana pendant ce temps là
le jeûne le genou de bec Abdou et ben
aura une vraie repos on va avoir ici
demain les deux matchs des à 12h donc
karwana Moussa et wanforest entre le
gagnant de cavalamoussa dommage demain
pendant que Abdou tranquille son canapé
il va observer les demi-finales et la
finale et la grande finale se jouera du
coup vendredi à partir de 17h également
voilà voilà donc je vais revenir sur la
flemme de de départ
et hop là donc merci à tous en tout cas
d'avoir suivi ce petit stream très sympa
je vous souhaite du coup de passer une
excellente soirée on se voit demain à